GOOD AND WELCOME. THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND TODAY'S HEARING
COVERS HEALTH RELATED BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DELIVERED TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON APRIL FIRST. OUR
NEXT SUB ONE HEARING WILL BE
THIS WEDNESDAY AND THAT HEARING
WILL ALSO COVERED THE APRIL
FIRST BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS ON
HUMAN SERVICES. FOLLOWING THIS
WEEK'S HEARINGS WE WILL HAVE
HEARINGS THE WEEK OF MAY
SIXTEENTH ON THE MAY REVISION.
AS USUAL I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY.
WHILE ALSO ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION.
TODAY'S HEARING IS AT THE STATE
CAPITOL IN HEARING ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. MANY OF THE
PANELISTS WILL BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY WHILE OTHERS WILL BE IN
PERSON AT THE CAPITOL. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR ONE TWO SEVEN. IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER ALL
MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
QUESTIONS FOR ALL OF THE PANELS.
THERE WILL BE NO VOTES TAKEN IN
TODAY'S HEARING FINALLY WE WILL
ALSO BE ACCEPTING WRITTEN PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK THROUGH
THE SOMEONE EMAIL ACCOUNT. AND
THE ADDRESS IS BUDGET SUB ONE AT
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. LET US BEGIN
WITH PANEL ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM MOST PROUD HE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY WHICH WE WILL REFER TO
AS EMSA HAS REQUESTED YOUR
TRUSSELL INSIST CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION WILL PROVIDE A
BRIEF BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
MULTI COUNTY LOCAL EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AGENCY FUNDING
INCREASE BUDGET PROPOSAL. I GET
AFTERNOON USE WERE TROUBLESHOOT
WAS VERY FEW WINDS UP. MERCY
MEDICAL REPORT REQUIRE TWO
MILLION CHUM DIAL HANNEL FUND
ONGOING SUPPORT CALPERS. MULTI
COUNTY WHAT ONE SEEM SERVER THE
IF YOU SEE. THIS WE'RE TALKING
EXISTING REESE FROM ALL
CAROLINE'S TO CREATE DOT
TOMORROW MANDATED. IN ADDRESS
SERVICE GAPS BY INCREASES
INCREASED IS ONE POPULAR GROWTH
INCREASED SO. ARE WE THERE ARE
THREE THREE ONE ZERO PROVIDE YOU
MUST WITH THE STATE. AND LOCAL
BE THIRTY THREE ONES WELL THERE
ARE TWENTY SINGLE COUNTING ON.
SEVENTY YOUNG SO ASSEMBLY CAN
ONES GUILTY THIRTY TWO IT WAS
WITH THE COUNTY IN PROVIDE US TO
OUR RESIDENTS POPULAR MORE SICK
MOVING WITHOUT. OR. THOUSAND
RESPOND THIS SUPPLEMENTAL STATE
FUNDING IS TO BE USED TO PROVIDE
ONLY ESSENTIAL MINIMUM SERVICES
NOT THIRD OPERATE THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
WORKERS ARE DEFINED BY HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SECTION FROM TWO
NINETY SEVEN DOT ONE WEIGHT IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL STATE FUNDING EACH
MONKEY COUNTY RUNS AMOK CONTAIN
AT LEAST THREE CALORIES AND ALSO
PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS OR WILL
LOSE ONE DOLLAR FROM EACH
DOLLARS RECEIVED MULTI COUNTY
MEMBERS OF THE POPULATION. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. RECEIVE A FULL
AMOUNT FOR THIRD OWN PEOPLE IF
THEY PROVIDE NOW OF AT LEAST
FORTY ONCE BURKE CHAPEL. DURING
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ALL ELIGIBLE
FAMILY LOANS- RECEIVED. GENERAL
FUND A LOT. MULTI FAMILY RENTALS
ARE NOT RECEIVING THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE YEAR NINETY NINETY
NINE FILE. FOR OVER TO THAT JOHN
LOVES ALL COSTS AND THOSE
LOOKING TO KEEP IT OBJECTIVE.
THE SMALL STATE FUNDING FOR
CENTRAL. BUT THE MULTI EVEN
PROVIDE IS REDUCED FROM TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION TO TWO POINT. TWO NO OBSCENITIES GENERAL
FUND ON. WHAT IS READY WHEN
SEVEN FORCED CONTINUE TO READ
LOCAL. USED TO SALUTE THE- WE-
LET US ARE FACING CHOI ABOUT
WHICH YOU SERVICES MUST BE FOR
WOMEN'S CHRISLEY'S. WILL
UNDERMINE THE WHIMS OF ABILITY
PLEASE WHEN AND ABOUT. YOUR WE
MUST IS THE- INCLUDING PRICES.
IN GENERAL. PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE. THEREFORE TO MEET
INCREASED LEAN MUSCLE SPONSORED
THANK YOU IN HAVE CRITICAL.
MISTER IN THE TO INSTALL DURING. FOR MULTI COUNTY WILL WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. OKAY COUNTY
BECAUSE OF ALSO FORCED TO
CONCEDE REMOVED THREE TO THE
MOST CRITICAL. A GIVEN CHART
OTHER CRITICAL POINTS IN
REMEMBER TO INCREASE IN AREAS
SUCH AS THOSE OF TWO SMALL. TO
DIFFERENT YEAH ACTUALLY OF A
MOBILE CAL MEMBERS OF THE ONE OF
A ONE STOP. FOUR FACT FINDING
NEEDS OUT OF DETROIT THE. WHAT
FUNDING ARMING TO WITH BY
DEFENSE INSTEAD. I'M JUST SORT
WITH WOOD COUNTY MULTI COUNTY
LOS RECKLESS ONE OF AT THE
BOTTOM YOUR A BREAK IN PIECES TO
HELP MANAGE. NUMBER THREE MARKET
TO. WITH.
THE BCPS CITES THE LARGE TOURISM
INDUSTRY IN MANY OF THE SMALL
RURAL COUNTIES AS A BASIS FOR
INCREASED EMS COSTS. ALL RIGHT
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES. EQUAL OR LARGER
CONTRIBUTOR TO EMS COSTS IN
NEEDS IN THESE COUNTIES. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO THIS QUESTION LIKE
THE GROWTH IN TOURISM DISASTERS
AND PARTICULARLY MORE AND MORE
INTENSE WILDFIRES HAVE INCREASED
BOTH A FIXED AND INCREMENTAL
COSTS TO EMS SYSTEMS THROUGH
MOST OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE M.
AND- INCREASES IN BOTH DISASTERS
AND TERRORISM REQUIRE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF MORE FIXED
RESOURCES LIKE ADDITIONAL
AMBULANCES AND ADD TO THE
INCREMENTAL COST GENERATED. LOS
ANGELES RESPOND TO MORE
EMERGENCIES. THE MULTI COUNTY
LOCAL EMERGENCY SERVICES AGENCY
BUDGET HANGE PROPOSAL ADDRESSES
THE NEEDS OF THE AGENCY WHO PLAN
COORDINATE AND OVERSEE THE CMS
RESOURCES FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS
COUNTIES. IN PARTICULAR THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY
INCREASES AS THE M. S. SYSTEMS
CALLED UPON TO RESPOND TO MORE
EMERGENCIES. WHETHER THOSE
EMERGENCIES ARE GENERATED BY
DISASTERS LIKE INVALID IT'S
ACCURATE IN A HOSPITAL
THREATENED BY WILDFIRE OR
WHETHER THOSE EMERGENCY
RESPONSES ARE TO A HIGHWAY
ACCIDENT INVOLVING A FAMILY
VISITING. THE MULTI COUNTY
LANCE'S JURISDICTION. IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE FOR HIM TO DETERMINE
THE RELATIVE COST OF DISASTER
VERSUS TOURISM TO EMS SYSTEMS.
BOTH HOWEVER CLEARLY IMPACT
MULTIFAMILY LYNCH'S ABILITY TO
FULFIL THEIR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. MULTI COUNTY LOCAL
pFUNDING INCREASE PROPOSAL
REFLECTS THE FUNDING GAPS
IDENTIFIED BY EACH OF THE MULTI
COUNTY LAPSES. DISASTER RESPONSE
ACCOUNTS FOR NEARLY ONE QUARTER
OF THOSE IDENTIFIED NEEDS. THAT
IS FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND OF TWO MILLION TEN
THOUSAND FUNDING REQUEST. A RICH
RUSSELL AND I ARE PREPARED TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR
ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS. C. NON I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANEL ONE
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PROPOSALS
FROM H. CHI. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS INFORMATION
SPECIFICALLY. PANEL TO WAS ON
THE HEALTH WORKFORCE PER PROGRAM
PROGRAMS AND THE CENTRAL
SERVICES. RESOURCES B. C. P. WE
WILL HAVE ONE PRESENTER ON THIS
PANEL AND IT WILL BE KAREN
RESULT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AT EACH CAR. CAN YOU
PLEASE BEGIN. CERTAINLY GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR RAMBLING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M- SO THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST THIRTY TWO
POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE STAFF RESOURCES NECESSARY
FOR H. CHI TO IMPLEMENT MULTIPLE
NEW AND EXPANDING HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST POSITION
OF AUTHORITY AND WE USE EXISTING
RESOURCES TO FUND THESE
POSITIONS. THE INCREASE OF
THIRTY TWO PERMANENT POSITIONS
IN THIS PROPOSAL WILL SUPPORT ON
GOING OPERATIONAL CAPACITY
NEEDED TO BUILD AND ADMINISTER
H. KAISE HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. AND THE
CENTRAL SERVICES NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS. THESE
POSITIONS WILL ABOUT AGE CRIED
TO SUCCEED AT ARE VASTLY
EXPANDED HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS PORTFOLIO. INCLUDING
SCHOLARSHIPS LOAN REPAYMENT AND
STIPEND AWARDS TO INDIVIDUALS
PIPELINE AND CAREER EXPLORATION
PROGRAMS AN ADDITIONAL GRANT
AWARDS TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ADMINISTER. HEALTH WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS. THE INCREASE CENTRAL
SERVICES CAPACITY WILL MEET
OPERATIONAL NEEDS AND
PROGRAMMATIC AND STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ARCHFORD WAS
RECAST AS H. CRY RECOGNIZING
ARCHED H. CARS GROWING
RESPONSIBILITIES ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREA OF HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THESE CHANGES
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED H. CARDS
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS FUNDING FROM
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION. IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. A FOUR FOLD INCREASE
. THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL BILLION DOLLARS IN
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT FOR H. CHI
TO ADMINISTER. A HUGE GROWTH THE
SAYS ATTAINING ADDITIONAL STAFF
. IN ADDITION TO INCREASE
FUNDING RECENT BUDGETS HAVE
INCREASED THE TYPE OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS H. CRIES ADMINISTERING
. FOR EXAMPLE H. CHI IS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROPOSED FOR
PROGRAMS SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELORS AS WELL AS A
NEW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH
CLASSIFICATION AND SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE WORK TO SUPPORT THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. OTHER NEW WORK BEGAN
WITH THE RECAST INCLUDE
ESTABLISHING A NEW CALIFORNIA
HEALTH WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL. A NEW RESEARCH
DATA CENTER AND BECOMING THE
STATE OFFICE OF RURAL HEALTH. IN
ADDITION THE PROPOSED TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET INCLUDES
PROGRAMMATIC AND FUNDING CHANGES
TO AGAIN EXPAND THE BREADTH AND
DEPTH OF H. CRIES HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. HOUSE
CHANGES INCLUDE BUILDING A NEW
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
WORKFORCE. EXPANDING TRAINING
FOR NURSING SOCIAL WORK AND
PSYCHIATRY WORKFORCE. AND
BUILDING A MULTI LINGUAL
WORKFORCE BETTER ABLE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE POPULATION
. SO FOR THESE POSITIONS
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
ACTIVITIES WE ARE REQUESTING
TWELVE NEW POSITIONS FUNDED OUT
OF THE PROPOSED TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION. EIGHT OF THESE
POSITIONS WILL DIRECTLY SUPPORT
H. CRAZIEST THING AND YOU
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. AND THREE
POSITIONS WILL PERFORM ESSENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT SUCH AS
IN CONTRACTS AND BUDGETS. WE'RE
ALSO REQUESTING A NEW HEALTH
EQUITY COORDINATOR POSITION
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT OUR WORK TO
RECRUIT TRAIN HIGHER ADVANCE AN
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE HEALTH AND SIR HUMAN
SERVICES WE WORKFORCE. TO
SUPPORT THE NEW PROGRAM STARTED
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE ARE
REQUESTING FIVE POSITIONS. THESE
POSITIONS ARE FUNDED FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPROPRIATIONS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE FROM THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE FUNDS. THE POSITIONS
CORRESPOND WITH WORK LORD OF NEW
AND EXPANDING PROGRAMS. THIS
INCLUDES STAFF TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE WORK OF THE CHILDREN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. AND STAFF TO SUPPORT
THE NEW HEALTH PROFESSIONS
CAREER OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMMER
HAVE. SUITE OF PROGRAMS. WE ARE
ALSO REQUESTING POSITION
AUTHORITY FOR TWELVE POSITIONS
TO ALIGN WITH OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THESE POSITIONS ARE
ALREADY FUNDED FROM PREVIOUS
ONGOING APPROPRIATIONS SUCH AS
THE ONGOING SONG BROWN GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATION AND FROM THE
HEALTH DATA AND PLANNING FUND.
EIGHT OF THESE POSITIONS
CORRESPOND WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS WORKLOAD THAT WAS
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTED YOUR
TEMPORARY POSITIONS. THIS
INCLUDES POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM AND OUR
ELEVEN LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS. FOUR OF
THE POSITIONS CORRESPOND WITH
THE EXISTING OPERATIONAL
WORKLOAD OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SUPPORTED ALSO SUPPORTED THE
TEMPORARY POSITIONS AND THIS
INCLUDES WORK FOR PROJECT
MANAGEMENT AND PROGRAM
COMMUNICATIONS AND OUTREACH.
FINALLY WE ARE REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS NECESSARY TO CENTRALLY
SUPPORT H. CRISIS INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
THESE POSITIONS ARE ALSO FUNDED
BY CURRENT AND PREVIOUS
APPROPRIATIONS. TO OTHER
POSITIONS WILL OVERSEE A BROADER
ADMINISTRATIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORT H. GUYS OVERALL MISSION
OPERATIONAL NEEDS AN
ORGANIZATIONAL PLANS. THIS
INCLUDES OUR EFFORTS TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN AGE GUYS WORKFORCE
INCLUDING WORK FOR SUCCESSION
PLANNING. AND ONE POSITION AS
NECESSARY TO ADMINISTER MINISTRY
TO FULLY SUPPORT THE INCREASED
WORK FOR LOAD FOR A NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY THOSE
ADMINISTERED BY OUR STATE OFFICE
OF RURAL HEALTH. I WILL NOW
ADDRESSED THE OTHER QUESTIONS
RAISED IN THE AGENDA. I'M ONE
WAS THERE TO PROVIDE AN
APARTMENT IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE
ON HIP HOP. H. GUYS PREPARED
BEEN PREPARING TO IMPLEMENT A
NEW PORTFOLIO PROGRAMS UNDER THE
HIP HOP FUNDING AND STATUTES.
THERE WERE NUMBERS STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS AND IDEAS TO SUPPORT
PIPELINE CAREER PATHWAY
ACTIVITIES SO WE WANTED TO
DEVELOP A SUITE OF PROGRAMS THAT
IS THOUGHTFUL. WELL INTEGRATED
AND SUPPORTS THE INTENT OF THE
STATUTE AND THE GROUNDWORK LAID
OUT IN THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
REPORT. WE ARE PLANNING TO
RELEASE OUR NEW APPLICATION BY
MID JUNE AT LATEST. THIS PROGRAM
WILL CREATE A FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY FOR PIPELINE IN
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
CAREERS IN PRIMARY CARE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND ALLIED
HEALTH FOR EXAMPLE. THIS RELEASE
IS THE BEGINNING OF OUR WORK AND
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE GROWING AND
EXPANDING OUR SUITE OF PROGRAMS
OVER TIME. WE ARE AWARE THAT
THERE'S STRONG INTEREST BUT NO
SPECIFIC COLLEGES OR
UNIVERSITIES HAVE DIRECTLY
CONTACTED US. WE HAVE ALSO
EXECUTED THE GRANT AGREEMENT
WITH THE MANAGING AGENCY THE
FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. ANOTHER PIPELINE IN
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM. AND THAT
PROGRAM IS UNDERWAY. NEXT I
WANTED TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
pREGARDING- SONG BROWN. IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN H. GUY
RECEIVED A SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATION IN FUNDING FOR THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM ON THE ANNUAL
BUDGET WENT FROM SIX POINT SIX
MILLION ARE COMING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND DATA AND
PLANNING FUND TO AN ONGOING
THIRTY THREE MILLION
APPROPRIATED FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. WITH THIS NEW FUNDING WE
WERE ABLE TO START TRACKING OUR
PROGRESS TO DEMONSTRATE THE
IMPACT OF THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. SO WE WANTED TO REPORT
TODAY THAT SENSE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THE SONG BROWN
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
FUNDING HAS SUPPORTED THE
LAUNCHING OF TWENTY FIVE NEW
PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVED
ACCREDITATION. THE EXPANSION OF
TWENTY ONE EXISTING PROGRAMS.
AND ALTOGETHER ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE ADDITIONAL PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY SLOTS. OVERALL
DURING THIS TIME DURING THE
NUMBER OF SLOTS IN CALIFORNIA
GREW BY THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT SLOTS THE SONG BROWN
SUPPORTED TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE OF THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT IN SOCKS. IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THIS INCLUDES
SUPPORTING THREE NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. EXPANDING SEVEN
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SLOTS FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION NEARLY
HALF A SONG BROWN SUPPORTED
GRADUATES PROVIDE HEALTH CARE IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF SONG BROWN
SUPPORTED RESIDENTS ARE BLACK OR
HISPANIC COMPARED 211% OF THE
PRIME OVERALL PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE. IN TERMS OF
HOW IT CARE WILL INCREASE OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY. H. CAR CURRENTLY
HAS A SERIES OF GUIDELINES THAT
ENSURE PROPER USE OF GRANTS AND
PROGRAMS APPLY THEY CERTIFY THAT
THE INFORMATION THEY ARE PRIDING
PROVIDING IS TRUE AND ACCURATE.
FOR A SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE
GUIDANCE IN GRANT AGREEMENTS
THAT PROHIBIT THE PLANTING. OF
EXISTING STATE OR LOCAL FUNDS.
AND THE GRANT AGREEMENT REQUIRES
THE GRANT KEY TO KEEP CLEAR
RECORDS FOR AT LEAST THREE YEARS
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE USE OF THEIR
FUNDS. BEFORE WE BEGIN ANY
APPLICATION CYCLE WE PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WEBINAR TO
ANY POTENTIAL APPLICANTS. AND WE
ALWAYS REINFORCE THE
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT THE USE OF
THESE GRANT FUNDS. AND WHEN
PROGRAMS INVOICE US FOR PAYMENT
THEY CERTIFY THAT THE FUNDING
WENT TO THE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING OF THE RESIDENTS THAT.
WE ARE SUPPORTING TO THIS
PROGRAM. H. PRESS CAREFULLY
CRAFTED OUR APPLICATION GRANT
AGREEMENT PROCESSES TO FULFILL
THE GOALS OF THE SONG BROWN AS
DESCRIBED AUDITING THIS PROGRAM
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AND RESOURCES. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. WITH THAT I WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR ANY
MEMBERS QUESTIONS C. NON I WILL
KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR ALL
START WITH EACH COPPER HIP-HOP
OR- HOWEVER YOU WOULD. LIKE IT
TO BE AS AN ACRONYM I'M QUITE-
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT BY MID
JUNE THERE WILL BE APPLICATIONS
OUT AT THE LATEST. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION DOES THAT MEAN BY
THIS FALL THAT SOME OF THESE
PATHWAYS WILL BE UP AND RUNNING.
AND THEN IF I CAN YOU DIDN'T
IDENTIFY ANY SPECIFIC SCHOOLS
BUT HAVE WE DONE OUTREACH
TOWARDS. EITHER THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS OR THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO DO A BROAD
PRESENTATION TO THOSE-
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD LOVE AN
UPDATE ON. I'M SO- WE HAVE NOT
DONE THE OUTRAGE BUT I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE STARTING TO DO
IS I'M DO MORE OUTREACH AND
WEBINARS TO ANNOUNCE OUR
PROGRAMS AND SO WE WOULD
CERTAINLY- BE I'M VERY HAPPY TO
DO THAT I'M SO WHAT WE DO WANT
TO DO IS WITH THEIR PROGRAM
RELEASE IN JUNE THAT WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO AWARD APPLICANTS HERE
IN EARLY SUMMER- AND THEN WE
WOULD HOPE THAT SHORTLY
THEREAFTER THEY WOULD BEGIN
THEIR- THEIR PROGRAMS. I'M GONNA
TRANSITION TO THE SONG BROWN- IT
WAS VERY ENCOURAGING TO HEAR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE NEW PROGRAMS
AND- AND EXPANSION OF TWENTY
ONE. PROGRAMS BUT IT DIDN'T
SOUND AS IF WE HAD- BEEN ABLE
TO- VERIFY. WHETHER THE
INFORMATION WHICH HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED BY THE- INSTITUTIONS-
HAVE NOT SUPPLANTED FUNDING AND
SO. I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND-
OTHER THAN AN AUDIT HOW HOW
COULD WE ENSURE THAT THESE
PUBLIC RESOURCES WERE NOT USED
TO SUPPLANT CURRENT FUNDING FOR
GMB SLOTS. SO OTHER THAN AN
AUDIT WE ARE CONTINUING TO DO-
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING AND THAT
IS THAT A PROGRAM CERTIFIES AND
WHEN WE PAY THEM THEY CERTIFY
THAT THOSE FUNDING WERE USED TO
SUPPORT THE RESIDENTS. I'M WE
HEARD EARLIER THAT THERE ARE
THIRTY TWO POSITIONS WHICH ARE
BEING TRANSFERRED FROM TEMPORARY
TO PERMANENT POSITIONS. AND YET
WE ALSO HEARD FROM YOU THAT YOU
WOULD NEED FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE AND- LOOK AT THE-
PROGRAM ITSELF TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S- MEETING ITS DESIRED GOALS
INSTATED- OUTCOMES THAT THAT I'D
LIKE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
CLARITY WITH THESE EXPANSION
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY. AND SO IF
THAT REQUIRES- THE FUNDING IF
THAT IS NOT ABLE TO BE ABSORBED
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT STAFFING
RESOURCES I WOULD I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT WE THEN CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER WE NEED TO ADD
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM WILL BE EXPANDING
PROGRAM- SLOT SAYS- IT WAS
DESIGNED TO ONE SO I WOULD LOVE
APPROPRIATE FOLLOW UP- ONE.
THAT'S AVAILABLE. GREAT THANK
YOU WITH THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ISSUE THREE WHICH IS ON
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY BCP WE WILL HAVE
ONE PRESENTER ON THIS PANEL
WHICH IS DIRECTOR ELIZABETH
LANDSBERG OF H. KILEY- DIRECTOR
LANDSBERG CAN YOU PLEASE BEGIN.
OF COURSE GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ELIZABETH PLANS
FOR THE DIRECTOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION. THE OFFICE OF%
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY-
POLICY WAS PROPOSED IN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WAS PRESENTED
TO THIS COMMITTEE BACK IN
FEBRUARY. SINCE THAT TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COORDINATED
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND TOGETHER
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
ISSUE. A LOT OF THE TOPICS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN- PURSUING IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS INCLUDE TREATMENT
OF MEDICAL COSTS IN CALCULATING
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE. WHICH
PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE COST TARGETS. THE
BOARD STRUCTURE INCLUDING
CONFLICT RIGHT INTEREST STANDARD
AND ANTI TRUST CONCERNS. THE
DATES FOR SETTING THE COST
TARGETS COORDINATION BETWEEN
STATE AGENCIES FOR EXAMPLE ON
QUALITY IN EQUITY STANDARDS AND
THE ENFORCEMENT APPROACH
INCLUDING THE SIZE OF PENALTIES
AS WELL AS SEVERAL TECHNICAL
ISSUES WHICH COME UP IN IN A
BILL- WITH THIS BLANKS AND
COMPLEXITY. WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
REVISED BCP FOR SPRING FINANCED
LETTER CONSIDERATION HERE THE
REVISED BUDGET PROPOSAL REQUEST
INCLUDES A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO PHYSICIANS WE
WOULD RAMP UP THE FIRST YEAR WE
WOULD START WITH FIFTY EIGHT
POSITIONS AND BY YOUR THREE WE
WOULD BE FULLY STAFFED UP AT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO POSITIONS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE TIME
FUNDING OF THIRTY MILLION
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
WHICH SUPPORTS FIRST YEAR COSTS
AND A PORTION OF SECOND YEAR
COSTS AS WELL AS ONGOING GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT. AND THE ONGOING
ANNUAL COST FOR THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE A THIRTY ONE MILLION.
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND.
THE RESOURCES NEEDED FOR THE
OFFICE HAVE BEEN MODIFIED
SLIGHTLY AS WE CONTINUED AS
WE'VE MADE SOME CHANGES IN THE
TRAILER PARK TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER THE OFFICES SUCCESS SO
I'LL JUST GIVE A BRIEF SUMMARY
OF THE VCP STAFFING CHANGES. WE
DID OUT OF PLANNING AND
MANAGEMENT SEXUAL TO THE OFFICE
WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL TO
COORDINATING POLICY PLANNING AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT ACROSS
ALL ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM. THE
OFFICE WILL REQUIRE COMPLEX
POLICY AND STAKEHOLDER
ACTIVITIES SPANNING MANY
DIFFERENT SECTORS HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES AND POLICY AREAS. THE
DECISION OF THE SECTION CREATES
A DEDICATED ORGANIZATIONAL UNIT
TO PROVIDE THESE FUNCTIONS WITH
THE NEEDED CAPACITY. WE WILL
HAVE AN OUR REGION EDUCATION
TEAM TO FORGE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE HEALTHCARE ENTITIES SUBJECT
TO THE COST TARGETS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE EDUCATING AND INFORMING
AND WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE HEALTHCARE ENTITIES. ABOUT
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO REDUCE
COSTS WHILE MAINTAINING QUALITY
EQUITY WORKFORCE IN PRIMARY CARE
AND VESTMENT. WHAT WE WILL ALSO
HAVE A PLANNING AND GOVERNANCE
TEAM TO COORDINATE PROGRAM
PROGRAM POLICIES ACROSS ALL
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM INCLUDING
LEGISLATION AND REGULATIONS. THE
TEAM ALSO STAFF AND SUPPORT AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD INCLUDING
PREPARING MATERIALS- AND HELPING
ME MEMBERS ADMINISTRATIVE NEEDS
SO THE ATTENTION OF THE SECTION
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THESE FUNCTIONS AND THE
SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD- OF
STAFFING IN INDEPENDENT VERSUS
AN ADVISORY BOARD. WE'VE ALSO
CREATED A WORKFORCE IN PRIMARY
CARE UNIT WHICH WILL BE CENTRAL
TO MONITORING AND PROMOTING
HEALTH CARE WORK FOR STABILITY
AND MEASURING- AND PROMOTING
SYSTEM WIDE INVESTMENT IN
PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WE ALSO HAVE CREATED AN
ACQUISITION THE MANAGEMENT UNIT
GIVEN THE PROGRAM SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY WE REASSESS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT NEEDED-
AND ADDED THE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND I. T. SUPPORT
THAT WILL BE NEEDED. SO THOSE
ARE THAT THE BASIC CHANGES- FROM
LAST YEAR'S BCP THIS YEAR'S AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS FOR ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. I'M. WITH THAT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PANEL FOR WHICH
WILL PRESENT ON THE REDUCING THE
COST OF INSULIN B. C. P. WE WILL
HAVE TO PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING FOR SCHALKE GHANI
ASSISTANT SECRETARY AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. AND LUKE CUSTOMER-
SENIOR FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE L. A. L. LET'S BEGIN
WITH DISTANCE SECRETARY BEGUN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERUBS LED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
PEOPLE GETTING INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF THE APRIL ONE
PROPOSAL I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
SENATE BILL EIGHT TO ENACTED IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
WHICH CODIFIED THE CALLER X.
PROGRAM. CARRACKS CALLS FOR
STATEWIDE GENERIC MANUFACTURING
OF ESSENTIAL MEDICINES AND
HIGHLY CONCENTRATED. LOW
POLITICIAN DRUG MARKETS. SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRES CAL HHS TO ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH GENERIC DRUG
MANUFACTURING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE. ONE REQUIREMENT UNDER THE
BELT IS NOT PARTNERSHIPS. BURKE
GENERIC MANUFACTURING INCLUDE
THE PRODUCTION ABOUT LEASE ONE
FORM OF INSULIN PROVIDED THAT A
POSSIBLE PATHWAY FOR
MANUFACTURING A MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR RESIDENTS ON EXCESS. HOUSE
WIDELY DOCUMENTED THE INSULIN
MARKET HAS LONG APPEARED A
MODEST. THE MARKET FAILURES THAT
PLAGUE THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY. WHICHEVER IS ALTERED
IN KEEPING AND SELLING PRICES
HIGHER. CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
RESIDENTS ARE DIRECTLY HARMED BY
THESE COMPLEX MARKET FAILURES.
KELLY UNINSURED OR UNDERINSURED
DIABETICS OFTENTIMES MUST PAY
THE PRE REBATE LESS PRICE FOR
THEIR INSULIN. MANY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER YEAR TO FOR THEIR
LIFE SAVING MEDICINES MEDIC
MEDICATIONS. BASED ON NATIONAL
DATA AS MANY AS ONE AND FOR
DIABETICS CANNOT AFFORD THEIR
INSULIN AND DOES RATION OR OF
CITIES TAKING INSULIN ALTOGETHER
- AS HIGHLIGHTED BY PRESIDENT BY
DID DURING THE STATE OF THE
UNION. THE STATE IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO REMEDY THIS MARK
MARKET FAILURE BY BRINGING MORE
AFFORDABLE BIOSIMILAR INSULINS
TO CALIFORNIA. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIRED
PARTNERSHIPS UNDER SB FIVE TWO
BY INVESTING FIFTY MILLION INTO
BIOSIMILAR INSULIN DEVELOPMENT
WITH A CONTRACTOR. THE FIFTY
MILLION WOULD BE PAID OUT
ACCORDING TO A MILESTONE PAYMENT
SCHEDULE. THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO INVEST AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY MILLION. TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A CALIFORNIA
BASED MANUFACTURING FACILITY. IN
HIGH SKILL HIGH PAYING JOBS
WITHIN THE STATE. THE FACILITY
WOULD BE AT A JOINT AT A
LOCATION JOINTLY DETERMINE
BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
CONTRACTOR. CALLAGY JEFF WILL
PARTNER WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. CODERS LEVERAGING
ITS EXPERTISE AND BUSINESS
INVESTMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES. KELLY JUST
WILL LEAN ON GO BUSINESS
EXPERTISE TO MEDICATE RESCUE I'M
PROPERLY DELIVER ON THE PROPOSED
MANUFACTURING FACILITY. UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL TALLERES WOULD
IDENTIFY A PARTNER TO BRING. TO
MARKET BOKKOS INTERCHANGEABLE
BIOSIMILAR INSULINS WITH THE
GOAL THAT CALIFORNIANS. WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO INSULIN CENTER
FRACTION OF THE THREE HUNDRED
DOLLAR PER VIAL LIST PRICES
CURRENTLY CHARGED. INJECTING
SUCH STEEP PRICE COMPETITION
WOULD DISRUPT THE CURRENT MRKET
AND EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR MILLIONS OF DIABETICS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE CONSUMER
SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH A LOW
PRICED- CALAR EXPOSED TO MORE
INSULIN THE STATE SIXTEEN THAT
THE FOLLOWING BENEFITS AS PART
OF A POTENTIAL PARTNERSHIP. THE
FIRST WOULD BE PRIORITY ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS WILL HAVE A
PRIORITY SUPPLY. SO THAT THE
STATE'S BALLING BOWLING NEEDS
AREMET HOWEVER NO MILK MINIMUM
VOLUME COMMAND THAT WOULD APPLY
TO THE STATE. SECONDLY ARE WE
THE STATE'S SIX- BRANDING OF THE
CALORIFIC SINCE ONE PRODUCTS
THIS MEANS THAT THE INSOLENCE
WOULD BE SOLD. OUT WITHIN
CALIFORNIA- WITH SOME TYPE OF
WAY PLAYING- CALIFORNIA ELATED
BRANDING. OUT IT COULD HAVE A
LOCAL SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
GOLDEN BEARS OR SOME TYPE OF
VERBIAGE SUCH AS CALORIE ACCENTS. ONE BROUGHT TO YOU BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS A HIGHLY
UTILIZED. THIS TYPE OF LABEL
WALKER BROWN TO. AMONG STAKE AND
CROSS SUPPORTERS AND DEMONSTRATE
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT. TO
PROVIDING LOW COST PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. THIS THIRD WE THINK LOW
LOW COST IMPLEMENTATION.
DOCTORING IN WHICH THE STATE
ITSELF WOULD HAVE TOTAL
OWNERSHIP OF FACILITIES AND THE
PRODUCTION PROCESS. ORDER SHIPS
HERE CONTRACT MANUFACTURING ARE
LIKELY THE LOWEST COST LOWEST
REST AND MOST ASSERTIVELY
FEASIBLE OPTION. FOR THE STATE
TO BRING AFFORDABLE BIOSIMILAR
INSULINS TO MARKET. THE CONTRACT
MANUFACTURER WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PRODUCT ROLLOUT AND
DISTRIBUTION SO THAT THE
PRODUCTS ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIANS. FRIDAY OF
RETAILERS PHARMACIES AND OTHER
OUTLETS AS WELL AS MAIL ORDER
PHARMACY. TO QUICKLY EVACUATE IN
AGREEMENT WITH A CONTRACT
MANUFACTURER. STATUTE STATUTORY
CHANGES ARE ALSO PROPOSE THAT
WOULD PROVIDE CONTRACT EXEMPTION
AUTHORITY FOR H. KIND THE
IMPLEMENTING DEPARTMENT FOR
CALAR ACTS. THIS CONTRACT
EXEMPTION WOULD ENABLE THE
QUICKEST PATH FOR CONSUMERS
ACCESS BIOSIMILAR INSULINS. IN
THE FUTURE CALAR ACTS COULD ALSO
ENTER INTO PARTNERSHIPS FOR
OTHER DRUGS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING MARKET FAILURES
BESIDES SENSE ONE. BY BRINGING A
LOT OF CONSTANCE WANT TO MARKET
REFLECTS THE PRIORITIES OF BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR LOWERING
PRESCRIPTION DRUG OSTS. THIS
MEANS SAVINGS TO THE UNINSURED
UNDERINSURED AND THOSE WITH HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE. ALL PLANS AS THESE
CONSUMERS ARE EXPOSED TO HIGH
WEST PRICES. AS WELL AS THE
HEALTH PLANS WHO CAN OBTAIN A
LOCAL LICENSE ONE THAN WHAT THEY
CURRENTLY GET ENOUGH PRICES
AFTER PHARMACY REBATES. THERE IS
A HIGH POTENTIAL FOR ADDITIONAL
SAVINGS TO THE BROADER MARKET.
YEP OVERTIME THE BRANDED INSULIN
MAKERS LOWER THEIR PRICES IN
RESPONSE. ASIAN HELLO THERE
WOULD BE INCREASE ADHERENCE TO
INSULIN REGIMENS THEREBY
IMPROVING THE HEALTH OUTCOMES OF
DIED DIABETICS AND ELIMINATING
ADVERSE EVENTS FROM RATIONING.
SUCH AS DIABETES KETOACIDOSIS.
ENCLOSING THE STATE BUDGET ACT
MANUFACTURING AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABLE INSULINS WILL PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR MILLIONS OF DIABETICS
AND ENERATE STATEWIDE. SYSTEM
STATES GENERATE SYSTEM WIDE
SAVINGS AND ADVANCE THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ADAPT TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES IN OUTCOMES
EXPERIENCED BY THOSE WITH
DIABETES. R. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON
THE AGENDA. THANK YOU FIRST WE%
WILL HEAR FROM THE L. L. THANK
YOU LICORICE MORROW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE
WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE PROPOSAL DEFINITELY HAS THE
POTENTIAL IF IT IS SUCCESSFUL TO
REDUCE THE COST OF INSULIN FOR
CALIFORNIANS BOTH ITS RESIDENTS
AND FOR THE STATE AS A- ENTITY-
YES. THANK YOU.
MAYBE MORE OF AN ALBUM. RICHARD
THIS. YES NORTH. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE CAGE MORROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
SORRY FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THERE- WANTED OF
COURSE START OFF BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE PROPOSAL
IF IMPLEMENTED- SUCCESSFULLY
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE COST CALIFORNIANS PAY FOR
INSULIN- BOTH ON THE RESIDENTS
AND ALSO AT THAT THE STATE AS AN
ENTITY THAT BUYS INSULIN-
HOWEVER THERE ARE NUMBER OF
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTIES
INVOLVED WITH THIS PROPOSAL-
FIRST OF ALL THERE'S THE
VIABILITY OF- WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD BE
SUCCESSFUL IN BRINGING A PRODUCT
TO MARKET WE NOTE THAT THIS PART
OF HAS BECOME A LOT EASIER DUE
TO CHANGES IN FEDERAL ELECTIONS
HOWEVER AND ARE STILL ON A
NUMBER OF REGULATORY AND OTHER
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES THAT
WOULD BE INVOLVED IN BRINGING UP
BIOSIMILAR AND INTERCHANGEABLE
INSULIN PRODUCT TO MARKET
MEANING THAT THE PRODUCT IS
SIMILAR TO THE INSULIN THAT'S
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE AND ALSO
THAT A PHARMACY COULD SUBSTITUTE
A BRAND NAME INSULIN WITH THE
PRODUCT- AND NOTABLY IT WOULD
LIKELY BE REQUIRED WORKING WITH
A CONTRACTED BORROWED THAT
DOESN'T HAVE. ONE THESE PRODUCTS
ON THE MARKET CURRENTLY. SO IT'S
ON HOW STATE INTO WOULD BE
PROTECTED BOTH IN THE NEAR AND
LONG TERM- THIS WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND WHAT
THE MINISTRATIONS INDICATED THAT
THE RELEASE OF THE FUNDING TO
THE CONTRACTED PARTNER. WOULD BE
TIED TO HITTING CERTAIN
MILESTONES. DETAILS ON THESE
MILESTONES HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED AT THIS TIME. AND IN
THE LONGER TERM WANT TO CONTRACT
APARTMENT HAS RECEIVED THE FULL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IT'S UNCLEAR
WHAT LEVEL DID WOULD REMAIN FOR
THE STATE TO PROTECT ITS
INTERESTS. IN ADDITION THE
MINISTRATION HAS INTENDED THAT
INTENDS TO KEEP. A RELATIONSHIP
WITH A PARTNER BEYOND THE
FUNDING PERIOD IN ORDER TO HELP
MAINTAIN IN SHORT THE PRICES
STAY LOW. HOWEVER THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS RELATIONSHIP REMAINS
UNCLEAR AND POTENTIALLY COULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL LEGAL
LIABILITIES FOR THE STATE. AND
THEN FINALLY THERE WAS A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT BUILT
INTO THIS PROPOSAL-
DEMONSTRATION HAS STATED THAT IT
INTENDS TO WORK WITH A
CONSULTANT TO MONITOR THE
CONTRACTED PARTNERS- PROGRESS
BUT THIS INFORMATION WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE SHARED. WITH THE
OR BE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC OR
THE LEGISLATURE. THIS LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY IS
FOR THE COMPOUNDED BY THE
MINISTRATIONS REQUEST FOR AN
EXEMPTION FROM THE STATE'S
CONTRACTING ROLE THROUGH THE END
OF TWENTY THIRTY TWO. AND ALL
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF THIS
CONTRACT COULD JUST FIND
EXEMPTION FROM THE CONTRACTING
RULES IT'S UNCLEAR WHY THIS
EXEMPTION SHOULD EXTEND BEYOND
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS WHEN THE FUNDING WINDOW
EXPIRES. UNDER THE PROPOSAL. WE
RECOMMEND THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSAL. IT
TAKES VARIOUS STEPS TO PROTECT
THE STATE INTERESTS AND PROVIDE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. FIRST
PRIOR TO THE STATE ENTER INTO
THE CONTRACT RECOMMEND REQUIRING
THAT THE MINISTRATION PROVIDE A
PROGRAM OUT LUMINARY LIST OF
MILESTONES THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE INCLUDING THE CONTRACT
INCLUDING STEPS. LEADING UP TO-
FDA APPROVAL. SECOND BECAUSE IT
IS UNCLEAR WHAT PRIORITY- I'M
SORRY WHAT PRICING WOULD BE- WE
RECOMMEND APPLYING A PROVISION
THE CONTRACTOR GRANT THE STATE
THE RIGHT TO PURCHASE INSULIN AT
COSTS AT LEAST UNTIL STATE
SAVINGS EXCEED THE STATE
INVESTMENT IN THE PARTNERSHIP.
THIRTY WE RECOMMEND REQUIRED TO
PROVISION THE CONTRACT THAT
PROVIDES FOR PENALTIES IF THE
CONTRACTOR PARTNER FAILS TO MEET
THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT TO
ENSURE THE STATE'S INTERESTS ARE
PROTECTED. FOURTH WE RECOMMEND
RECALL FOLLOWING THE- THE
NEGOTIATION WITH A PART TIME JOB
PORTAL BUT BEFORE THE CONTRACT
IS ENTERED INTO. THAT THERE BE A
LEGAL REVIEW BY. AN ENTITY SUCH
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH AN
EMPHSIS ON IS TRYING THAT ARE
PROVISIONS TO PROTECT THE
STATE'S INTEREST AND MINIMIZE
LIABILITIES. INCLUDING THE
STRUCTURE OF THE STATE TO LEAD
BEIJING STEP WITH THE CONTRACTED
PARTNER. IT RECOMMEND MAKING THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING CONTINGENT
ON A THIRTY DAY REVIEW PERIOD BY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OF THE CONTRACTED
TERMS AND- MILESTONES. AND SIX
BECAUSE THE MINISTRATION HAS
NOTED THAT THE PROPOSED FUNDING
ALONE WOULD NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO
IMPLEMENT. THE PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING THAT THE
CONTRACTED PARTNER DEMONSTRATE
ABILITY TO RAISE SUFFICIENT
CAPITAL TO COVER ANY REMAINING
COST ASIDE FROM THE STATE'S.
INVESTMENT AND THEN ONCE THE
CONTRACT IS ENTERED INTO
RECOMMENDER CLIMBING QUARTERLY
UPDATES TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. ON PROGRESS
TOWARD THE CONTRACTIN MAY
MILESTONES THIS WOULD ALLOW AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT. AND THEN
FINALLY THE LOGIC FROM MIGHT
WISH TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT THE BENEFITS AND TRADE
OFFS. OF IT IT FOR POSTAL TO
CONTINUE THE EXEMPTION OF STATE
CONTRACTING ROLL THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY TWO RATHER THAN AND YOU
HAVE AN ORDER OR DATE- THANK YOU
AND HAVE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU I AM
NOW GOING TO ASK- SECRETARY
PETANI TO- ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE AGENDA OR IF
THERE WAS SOMEONE ELSE WHO YOU
WERE ASSIGNING INSPECTIONS TO.
THAT IS FINE AS WELL. SURE THANK
THANK YOU DR- ARAMBULA TAKE ON A
FEW OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
ALTERNATE OVER LATER TO OUR
CHIEF COUNSEL AT EACH CHIRON
BUCKLEY- THE FIRST QUESTION- IN
THE AGENDA WAS FOR- WELL
PROVIDING A REACTION TO THE
CONCERNS AND- RECOMMENDATIONS
REYES BIO- SO I'D START OFF
WITH- YOU NOTING THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL POLICY WINDOWS KIND OF
ALIGNED TO MAKE IT APPROPRIATE.
AND WORTHWHILE FOR THE STATE TO
ADDRESS THE MARKET FAILURE OF
AFFORDABLE INSULIN FIRST OTHERS
GREATER LEGAL GROUP REGULATORY
CLARITY. THE BIOLOGICS PRICE
COMPETITION AND INNOVATION
IMPACT- WHICH WAS ENACTED- AND
TWENTY TEN VIA THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
REGULATORY PATHWAY FOR
PHARMACEUTICAL FIRMS TO BRING
BIOSIMILARS TO MARKET- SO. THE
VC PI HAS BEEN- DONE ON THE PATH
TO IMPLEMENTATION SINCE THE MID
TWO TWO THOUSAND TIMES AND THE
FDA HAS SINCE PUBLISHED SEVERAL
NOTABLE GUIDANCES ON BIOSIMILAR
INTERCHANGE ABILITY LICENSING
AND LABELING. THESE GUIDANCES
HAVE PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY. OR PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES THEREBY REDUCING OF
BIOSIMILAR DEVELOPMENT AND
PRODUCTION COSTS THERE'S ALSO
ONE EXISTING BIOSIMILAR INSULIN-
THAT THAT HAS COME TO MARKET
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE A TEMPLATE-
FOR HOW OTHERS CAN REPLICATE
THAT PROCESS. NUMBER TWO- THAT
THERE'S BEEN POLICY ACTION TO
ADDRESS THE HIGH COST OF DRUGS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED AS BE A PART
TO AS I AS I NOTED EARLIER. SO
IN THE BILL- THAT THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE EXPLORE-
PENCIL AND PROVIDED A VIABLE
PATHWAY EXCESS- AND LASTLY- YOU
KNOW BIG BASS OUR OUR OUR MARKET
RESEARCH OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. WE HAVE FOUND THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR- A VIABLE
PATHWAY- SPECIFICALLY THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTRACT
MANUFACTURING TO DELIVER LOW
COST OR OUT COST MOST SIMILAR
INSULIN PRODUCTS. THERE ARE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
UNCONVENTIONAL FIRMS AND START
UPS STARTUP FIRMS WITH PROVEN
TRACK RECORDS. THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED ALTERNATIVE MODELS FOR
DRUG DEVELOPMENT DISTRIBUTION
AND PRODUCTION. MOST IMPORTANTLY
THESE ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS HAVE
SHOWN THAT THEY CAN PARTNER WITH
THE STATE. AND BRING BIOSIMILAR
INSULIN PRODUCTS TO MARKET
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
WITHOUT A PARTIAL INVESTMENT
FROM THE STATE. AND NO
PURCHASING COMMITMENTS WHILE BAY
WOULD SHOULDER THE COST OF
DISTRIBUTION AND ROLL OUT. A
PARTNERSHIP VIA CONTRACT
MANUFACTURING HAS THE
SIGNIFICANT PROMISE OF
SUBSTANTIAL SYSTEM WIDE SAVINGS-
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENCE ONE COSTS
COULD DECREASE DUE TO STEEP
PRICE COME COMPETITION. AND THEN
I'LL I'LL COVER THE THIRD
QUESTION WE RECEIVE ON THE
AGENDA ABOUT THE STATE- WHETHER
THE STATE WOULD ON THE
MANUFACTURINGFACILITY- THAT
WOULD BE BUILT- SO IF THAT THE-
CALAR EXPLOSIVE MORE INSULIN
INITIATIVE USES THAT OUR
CONTRACT MANUFACTURING APPROACH.
THIS IS BECAUSE IT'S MORE
EFFICIENT AND TIMELY IN BRINGING
AFFORDABLE BIOSIMILAR AND SONS
TO MARKET- AS WE MENTIONED IN
THE PROPOSAL ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE
COULD BE. MANUFACTURING BY THE
STATE DRUG MANUFACTURING IS VERY
COSTLY AND COMPLEX- SINCE THIS
DAY WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE
BUILDING ITS NON. PHARMACEUTICAL
FIRM DOES WHAT INVOLVED YOU KNOW
THE STATE DEVELOPING. AT THE
DRUG SUBSTANCES IN PRODUCTS
BUILDING AND MANAGING FACTORIES
NAVIGATING THE LEGAL RIGHT OF
OUR SYSTEM AND- DISTRIBUTING
PRODUCTS CENTER WHOLESALERS AND
PHARMACIES. THIRD THROUGH
CONTRACT MANUFACTURING THE STATE
LOWERS ITS REST BECAUSE THEY
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE CONTRACT
MANUFACTURER TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE COST FOR THE INSULIN
MANUFACTURING FACILITY. WE
ANTICIPATE- THE TOTAL COST TO
ESTABLISH A FACILITY BUILDING IN
THE. RANGE OF A HUNDRED BILLION.
I WHICH WHICH ENOUGH TO THAT
PUTS CONSERVE WITH A REVIEW OF
THE MARKET AND ENGAGEMENT WITH
INDUSTRY EXPERTS. THE STATE
WOULD CONTRIBUTE- HALF OF THIS
COST FOR THE MANUFACTURING
FACILITY WHAT WITH THE
CONTRACTOR COVERING THE
REMAINDER OF. SO THE- AND AS I
NOTED EARLIER AND MY- REMARKS WE
WOULD YOU KNOW DO THAT DUE
DILIGENCE WITHOUT GO BESTED
MINISTRATION AND GO THERE'S
WORKING TOGETHER- TO CONFIRM IF
MANUFACTURING FACILITY IS
JUSTIFIED. WELL WE HAVE A STRONG
PREFERENCE TO LOCATE THE
FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
IT IT DID- OPPORTUNITY FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AS A AS AN
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT- WE CAN ALL
STAR CONSIDERATION WE HAVE TO
EXPLORE. INCLUDING WHETHER- A
POTENTIAL CONTRACT MANUFACTURER
MANUFACTURER HE HAS EXISTING
CAPACITY IN LOCATIONS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO TALENTED JUST
WOULD MAKE THIS DECISION AND
COORDINATION WITH CALLS AS- AND-
THERE ARE CONTRACTING PROCESS
WE'D INSURE THAT THE THAT THE
CONTRACTOR CONTINUES TO. TO USE
THE FACILITY TO MANUFACTURE
INSULIN AT A LOW TRANSPARENT
PRICE. AND BURKE FOR THE
REMAINING REMAINING QUESTIONS
ALTERNATE OVER TO RYAN BUCKLEY
CHIEF COUNSEL AT AGE FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS THIS ADDITIONAL
ARAMBULA KLAY G. COUNCIL HERE H.
GUY. FOR THE JOB BACK TO THE
SECOND QUESTION WHICH WAS PLEASE
EXPLAIN THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE PROPOSED PUBLIC CONTRACT
CODE EXEMPTION. BEING FOR SUCH A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME. I DIDN'T
EXEMPTION IS NEEDED BECAUSE
AGREEMENTS WITH CONTRACTING
PARTNERS WILL BE UNUSUAL
CONTRACTS THAT DID NOT FIT
SQUARELY WITHIN DDS COURT RULES
AND PROCEDURES. UNLIKE TYPICAL
CONTRACTS THE STATE IS NOT
DIRECTLY RECEIVING GOODS OR
SERVICES AND CONTRACTS WE
PERFORMED IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
HIGHLY REGULATED COMPLEX
INDUSTRY. BECAUSE OF THIS
UNIQUENESS THE AGREEMENTS WE
DIFFICULT FOR REVIEW UNDER
NORMAL CONTRACTING PROCESSES
WHICH MAY CAUSE SUBSTANTIAL
DELAYS. THE TEN YEAR EXEMPTION
IS NEEDED IF THE PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT FOR INSULIN HAS TO BE
AMENDED BEYOND FIVE YEARS
BECAUSE OF UNEXPECTED
CIRCUMSTANCES EFFORT POWER
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO ENTER A
PARTIAL. PUNISHES FOR OTHER
DRUGS THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
MARKET MARKET FAILURES BESIDES
INSULIN THE EXEMPTION BUT-
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
FIFTY TWO- ACROSS THE BOARD- D.
EXEMPTION WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
TO QUICKLY HIRE EXPERTS AND
CONSULTANTS AS NEEDED TO ASSESS
RESPOND TO DEVELOPMENTS AROUND.
THE PROGRAM IN THE INDUSTRY.
NEXT QUESTION BUT FOR ONE WHAT
BIGELOW. WITH THE STATE FACE
RESULT IN ITS AND WITH
MANUFACTURER. AS ENVISIONED
UNDER THE CURRENT B. C. P. THE
STATE WOULD NOT BE OWNING A
CONTROLLING ANY OF THE PRODUCTS
WITH THE MEANS OF PRODUCTION
TESTING DISTRIBUTION. SO THE
RISK LIABILITY THE STATE IN THAT
REGARD TO MINIMIZE. THESE GUYS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
RETAINING EXPERT COUNSEL TO
ADVISE THESE KIND THE
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS TO CARRY
OUT SB FIFTY TWO. IN THE
MONITORING. AND MONITORING
PERFORMANCE OF ANY AGREEMENTS
AROUND THAT. NUMBER FIVE HOW THE
STATE BE ABLE TO PROTECT ITS
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT. IF ANY
COMPONENT OF THE PROJECT FAILS.
IN THIS REGARD WE THINK
PREVENTION IS THE BEST MEDICINE
IN EIGHT CO AX MITIGATE THE
RISKS ON THE FRONT END. A. B. C.
P. SISTER SHARE THE RISK AS A H.
CAL WOULD NOT BE FUNDING THE
FULL COST OF DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PRODUCTS. WERE DISABILITIES. AND
WITH EACH MILESTONE SHOULD BE
CAREFULLY ASSESS ASSESSED AND
DEFINING CONTRACT IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR OWN
EXPERTS- AND SHOULD HAVE AN
INHERENT VALUE TO THE STATE
WHICH COULD BE THIS DISRUPTIVE
VALUE ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS COMING
IN THE PIPELINE OR COMPETITORS
ENTERING THE MARKET- EACH
MILESTONE SHOULD ALSO HAVE.
VALUE EVEN IF THE CONTRACT
DOESN'T END UP BEING FULLY
PERFORMED AS REGIONALLY VISIONS
WIFE IN CONTRACT THE BEST
PROTECTIONSTO CLOSELY MONITOR
THE CONTRACTORS PERFORMANCE
PROVIDE FOR FINANCIAL COVENANTS
AND CONDITIONS IN THE CONTRACTS
THAT'S THE STATE. CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE CONTINUED
VIABILITY THE CONTRACTOR AND THE
PRODUCTS PRIOR TO EACH
DISBURSEMENT. AND WITH THAT
HAPPY ANSWER FOR THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DÍAS FOR ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES THANK YOU-
OR VERY SO MUCH- SO YOU KEEP
USING THE WORD- CONTRACT
EXEMPTIONS WHAT IS THAT. MEAN IS
THAT NO BAD CONTRACTS IS WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO. YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT EXEMPTION FROM
NEET THE USUAL- STAY CONTRACTING
PROCESS. TO ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO TIME. YEAH SO THAT
MEANS NO BID CONTRACTS RIGHT
WE'VE ENTERED YOU KNOW- OKAY SO
IT'S A NO BID CONTRACT TO
CONTINUE WITH MY COMMENTS LATER-
THE OTHER QUESTION IS- THE-
QUESTION WAS NOT ANSWERED IF THE
STATE WILL ON THE- FACILITY IS
THAT A YES OR NO. NO BECAUSE WE
WENT THROUGH FIVE MINUTES OF
JUST. SPEAKING TO AND THE ANSWER
IS NOT SO WE WANT TO WIN BESTING
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
THE FACILITY THAT WE WILL NOT. A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT BCP WILL BE DIRECTED TO
A INVESTMENT OF FACILITY. SO WE
EXACT OKAY SO FIFTIES I'M SORRY
I'M CORRECTED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS UP TO A FACILITY THAT
WILL NOT. THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
AND THEN- SO. I BET THIS IS KIND
OF OUT OF MY LEAGUE HOWEVER I DO
HAVE NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN HERE
UPS MY SIXTY YEAR I'VE BEEN
HEARING NO BID CONTRACTS FOR A
LONG TIME WE HAD THE YOU KNOW
THE- FAILED- THEN- WITH THE
VENTURA- CONTRACT WHERE WE
INVESTED A WHOLE BUNCH OF MONEY
ON ON A COVERT TESTING SO MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD
ABOUT NO BID CONTRACTS. HAS NOT
BEEN GOOD AT ALL ABOUT THIS IS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN CAP LAST
YEAR- I SPECIFICALLY ASKED THE
NUMBER OF TESTING MAYBE RELATED
OR UNRELATED BUT MY POINT IS
THAT I HEAR THE SAME THING THAT
WE HEARD DURING THE WINTER A
CONTRACT FOR- FOR COLBY TESTING-
SO I JUST FEEL LIKE WE'RE
INVESTING A BUNCH OF MONEY AND
NINE THIRTY GETTING ANYTHING FOR
OUR- OUR INVESTMENT- I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A THING CALLED A PPM- SO
HOW WILL THE STATE ENSURE THAT-
WERE INCLUDED IN THAT- BILLS. M.
FORMULARIES- IN ORDER TO- BE
INCLUDED. AND KIND OF THIS WHOLE
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY
COMPLICATED. I CAN TAKE THIS
QUESTION- SO YEAH YOU YOU RAISE
A GOOD QUITE A POINT ABOUT PBMS
AND KIND AT HOW HOW THE INSULIN
PRODUCTS WOULD BE COVERED SO-
YOU KNOW CALAR ACTS WOULD WORK
WITH THE MET CONTRACT
MANUFACTURER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PRICE OF THE ENDS LINES ARE NOT-
INFLATED ALONG THE SUPPLY CHAIN-
YOU KNOW THIS THIS THIS HAPPENED
THE OUR CURRENT SYSTEM WHERE.
YOU KNOW FROM GOING FROM THE
MANUFACTURER TO THE WHOLESALERS
TO PBMS OF THE PRICE INCREASES
AT EACH POINT SO WE WOULD WORK
TO ENSURE THAT- TECHNICAL. TAKES
ACTIONS TO AVOID DOCTOR COTTON.
THEY'RE HAVING TERMS WITH- ALL
SAILORS AND PHARMACIES TO ENSURE
. AND TO ENSURE THAT THE INSULIN
PRODUCTS ARE PRICED- AT THE
MANUFACTURER'S SUGGESTED RETAIL
PRICE- THERE'S ALSO GOING TO BE-
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN INCLUDE
EFFORT SAID TO RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS ABOUT THE-
AVAILABILITY OF LOW COST. AND
ONE FOR THOSE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
EXPECTS IT TO THE HIGH WAS PRICE
OF BRANDED INSULIN'S- AND THEN-
IF FOR WHATEVER REASON PBMS AND
HEALTH PLANS DO NOT COVER THE
PRODUCT WE ALSO HAVE MAIL ORDER
PHARMACY AVAILABLE BUT BUT FOR-
WHAT WHAT YOU REYES ABOUT PBMS
IS PARTICULARLY NOTEWORTHY
BECAUSE- THERE ARE. THERE ARE A
LOT OF POLICIES BEING PROPOSED-
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND AS WELL
AS THE STATE OF INSULIN COPAY
CAPS SO IF THOSE WERE TO BE
ENACTED- THE CARD THAT PROVIDES
BENEFITS TO CONSUMERS IN TERMS
OF PREDICTABILITY OF OUT OF
POCKET COSTS BUT IT ALSO SHIFTS
THE COST TO HEALTH PLANS AND
PBMS SO- YOU. BUT THE BETTER OF
HAVING A LOWER. BIOSIMILAR
INSULIN PRODUCT ON THE MARKET IS
THAT HEALTH PLANS- WOULD HAVE
MORE OF AN INCENTIVE TO COVER
THAT PRODUCT SO THAT. BECAUSE
THEIR CURRENT MORE OF THE COST-
FOR COVERING THAT PRODUCT- HOW
DID THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN SENT TO
COVERED ON THEIR FORMULARY. SO
THAT THEY KNOW THE CONSUMER
PICKS UP THAT PRODUCT- ON THE
HEALTH PLANS EITHER TOTAL
EXPENSES WOULD GO DOWN BECAUSE-
THE PRICE OF THE PRODUCT IS FAR
LOWER THAN THE GRANDDAD'S- AND
THEN- YEAH AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER YOU KNOW- IF. HI IF THE
HEALTH PLANS AND PBMS ON COVER
OF MAIL ORDER PHARMACIES ANOTHER
OPTION- AND WE WOULD ALSO WORK
WITH THE CONTRACTOR TO ENSURE
THAT THAT NONTRADITIONAL RETAIL
CHAINS- SUCH AS OUR GROCERY
STORES OR OTHER TYPES OF VENUES
WHERE WE'RE CONSUMERS FREQUENTLY
SHOP- BUT THOSE COULD ALSO BE
OPTIONS FOR PROTECTING THE
PRODUCT. DR WOOD YEAH I JUST I
JUST LIKE TO FOLLOW UP- YOU KNOW
THE PBM ISSUE IS OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN AND I'VE- I'VE WORKED ON
THIS ARENA FOR A WHILE AND ONE
OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE IS THAT.
WE HAVE SEEN MULTIPLE EXAMPLES
OVER THE YEARS WERE PBMS- WON'T
TAKE A LOWER COST ALTERNATIVE ON
OF THE FORMULARY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T GET A BIG ENOUGH REBATE.
THEY OPERATE IN THE REBATE WORLD
AND SO IF WE'RE RELYING ON ON
CITIZENS TO REQUEST THAT- THEN
THEN THAT MAY BE OUTSIDE THE
CONTRACT AGREEMENT THEY HAVE
WITH THEIR INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND SO ON AND SO THE PRICE MAY
BE REALLY MAY BE REALLY. WHEN
LIKELY WILL BE REALLY REALLY
APPEALING. BUT THE WHOLE THE
WHOLE OF THE AGREEMENTS WITH
HEALTH PLANS AND PBMS INCLUDING
OUR OWN STATE WHO HAS USES
OPTUM. AS AS THAT ARE PRETTY
COMPLICATED SO- IS GREASE SOME
ASSURANCE THAT THERE'S SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY WORKING ON THIS PART OF
IT BECAUSE- IN SPITE OF THE FACT
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY
INSTITUTE A THIRTY FIVE DOLLAR.
YOU KNOW COPAY CAP- WHICH WHICH
IS WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THAT THAT THE FORMULARY WILL BE
PICKED UP- EVEN THOUGH WE MIGHT
PRODUCE IT FOR THIRTY DOLLARS.
DO YOU SEE WHERE I'M GOING WITH
THAT YEAH. YEAH THANK YOU WHERE
AN HOUR. AT I DO KIND OF WANTED
TO REFOCUS ON. CALM KIND OF WHAT
WHAT THE CALORIE EXPIRES SIMILAR
INSULIN PRODUCT WOULD BE IT
WOULD BE PRETTY
TRANSFORMATIONAL. BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE A PRODUCT THAT'S BASED
BASED ON COSTS SO. THE CONSUMER
COULD IT BE APPROXIMATE THE
CURRENT THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR PER
ABOUT ISIS PROFILE PRICES
CHARGED IN THE MARKET- UNINSURED
CONSUMERS ARTS WASN'T UP FOR
COST OF THAT. SO FOR US ABOUT
COST PRODUCT- ARE COMING TO THE
MARKET THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE.
DOT DOT CONSUMER COULD PURCHASE
IT ON THEIR OWN- ESPECIALLY ON
AN UNINSURED CONSUMERS WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH PLANS- YOU
KNOW THAT THE REBATE NEGOTIATED
AMOUNT SUCH THAT THE HEALTH
PLANS HAVE. SO THIS WOULD BE-
REALLY DISRUPTING OUT SPACE-
COULD YOU HAVE ONE PRODUCT ONE
TRANSPARENT LOW PRICED-
REGARDING HEALTH PLANS- MOST
INSURED CONSUMERS- HI YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE- MOST OF THEM
AT LEAST WITH GOOD COVERAGE TO
HAVE- YOUR COPAYS OR COINSURANCE
AMOUNTS THAT THA THEY NEED TO
PAY AND THEN- BUT THE CONSUMERS
THAT THAT HAVE A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLANS WHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN MET THAT DEDUCTIBLE THEY
WOULD ALSO BE- SIMILAR TO THE
UNINSURED CONSUMER HAVING TO
BEAR THE WHOLE COST- BEFORE THEY
YOU KNOW BEFORE THE HEALTH PLAN
PICKS UP THE REMAINDER. SO FOR
THESE TWO- TWO GROUPS CONSUMERS-
IT WOULD BENEFIT THEM. FROM
PROPOSED BY HAVING. ACCESS TO A
LOW COST PRODUCT THAT THEY THAT
THEY COULD PAY FOR OUT OF THERE
ARE USING THEIR OWN OUT OF
POCKET. FUNDS I GUESS WITH THE
CHAIR JUST TO FOLLOW UP AND I
AND I APOLOGIZE AND I'M PROBABLY
GETTING WAY INTO THE WEEDS ON
THIS BUT- BUT- BUT I. I YOU KNOW
I WONDER OKAY SO YOU HAVE
CONSUMERS WHO'S GOT A HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN- AND PRESUME OF
HIS HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN SHOULD
BE COVERING- THE COST. OF SOME
OF THE COSTS FOR THE FOR THE FOR
THE DRUG. BUT WE MIGHT WE MIGHT
ULTIMATELY BE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO GO OUTSIDE THEIR INSURANCE
PLAN. BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOWER
COST ALTERNATIVE. FOR THEM- IT
WAS NOT QUITE AN OVER THE
COUNTER BECAUSE IT'S A
PRESCRIPTION- SO WE'VE GOT THIS
SOMETHING THAT'S KINDA IN
BETWEEN HERE. MEANWHILE THE
PREMIUM REFLECTS. WHAT THE COST.
SHOULD BE SO THAT'S GIVING AN
ADVANTAGE TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES- THE PBMS MAY NOT
CARRY IT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING A BIG ENOUGH REBATE.
THERE SO SOME OPERATIONAL ISSUES
HERE THAT ARE OF CONCERN- AND I
YOU KNOW I JUST. I GUESS I'M
HOPING THAT THERE'S SOMEBODY.
REALLY LOKING DEEPLY AT THAT
SOME OF THIS BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
COMPLICATED. AND I'M JUST
TOUCHING THE SURFACE OF THE
SENATE AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT. THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
WHERE WE'RE CONSIDERING AND
LOOKING AT EXPLORING FURTHER- WE
WHAT WE WILL AS PART OF THIS IS
A NATIONALLY WE WILL BE.
BRINGING ON AN EXPERT CONSULTANT
TO HELP WITH THE STRATEGIC- WITH
STRATEGY OPERATIONS- YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE THING TO GET YOUR
PRODUCT TO MARKET IT'S ANOTHER
ENTIRE- IT'S ANOTHER SORT OF
CHALLENGE. TO ACTUALLY GET IT IN
THE HANDS OF CONSUMERS. SO WITH
THAT AT EXPERT CONSULTANT THEY
WOULD BE TASKED WITH FIGURING
OUT STRATEGIES. FOR ENGAGING
HEALTH PLANS AND PBMS ON ON HOW
TO COVER COVER THAT THE CALORIE
ACCENTS ONE PRODUCT. YEAH AND
THEN JUST FINALLY BEGIN I KNOW
THIS FROM I KNOW THIS IS
HAPPENED I'VE TALKED TO- TO-
SOME PEOPLE IN THE MANUFACTURING
WORLD. THAT HAD ARTIFICIALLY IMP
CREASE THE PRICE OF THEIR
PRODUCT. TO BE ABLE TO APPEAL TO
A PBM TO GET THREE THAT PBM
INTERESTED TO REBATE. SO THEY
COULD ACTUALLY PLAY IN THAT
SPACE AND SO. THIS IS A REAL
CONCERN THE PBM ISSUE SO- I JUST
YOU KNOW ALSO STOP THERE BUT-
IT'S POTENTIALLY PRETTY MESSY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. WHAT
THANK YOU DR ED FOR- I'M NOT IN
IN THAT PROFESSION HOWEVER- I DO
HAVE A CONSERVE OUR FIRST OF
ALL- AS A TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT HOPE IS NOT A STRATEGY. SO
I'M NOT HERE ANY HEARING ANY
STRATEGIES AS TO HOW THIS IS
GOING TO BECOME AVAILABLE THE L.
A. O.'S- CONCERNS I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE L. A. O. WE'VE
ENTERED INTO NO BID CONTRACTS
BEFORE SO THIS. EXPERT
CONSULTANT THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WOULD BE UNDER NO BID
CONTRACT AS WELL SO HOW. YOU
KNOW. THE NUMBER OF ISSUE THAT
ALREADY POPPING INTO MY HEAD. AS
TO YOU KNOW HIRING THESE EXPERT
CONSULTANTS BEING THE- KIND OF
FIASCO THAT I EXPLAINED TO YOU
EARLIER ABOUT. THE VENTURA
FACILITY THERE WAS NO BIG
CONTRACTS- AND THAT AS WELL THEY
WERE NOT- FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
THE PROMISE OF. CHEAPER BECAUSE
IT ENDED UP BEING THAT WE WERE
PAYING MORE FOR THAT- THE
COVERAGE HAS INSTEAD OF LEFT.
THE FOR EXAMPLE ONLY U. S. T.
AND- SAN DIEGO SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR PAYING LESS WITH OTHER.
VENDORS AS WE WERE- PROVIDING
THROUGH THE VENTURA CONTACTS SO
IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE TO ME HOW
WE CAN SAY NO BID CONTRACTS WHEN
IT'S SUCH A- SENSITIVE ISSUE.
AND TO THE POINT OF THE PBMS
THAT DOESN'T GUARANTEE. SOUNDS
GREAT THAT THAT FOLKS ARE GOING
TO HAVE OF CHEAPER INSULIN- BY
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE THAT THAT
BILLS WILL BE PAID FOR AND WHAT
I HEARD YOU SAY. WAS THAT THE
FOLKS THAT DON'T HAVE INSURANCE
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT. WHO'S GOING TO. WRITE THE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR THIS MAGIC IN
FULL AND THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE WHO'S GOING TO WRITE A
PRESCRIPTION. FOR THIS CHEAPER
BECAUSE YOU STATED. THAT FOLKS
THAT DON'T. THERE'S NOBODY
WRITING A PRESCRIPTION
CONNECTION CAN YOU AT LEAST THAT
I CAN. I CAN CLARIFY THAT THAT
MEAN- UNINSURED- PERIODS CAN YOU
KNOW COME IN A VARIETY OF FORMS
AS IT COULD BE COVERAGE
TRANSITIONS IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
AGING OUT OF YOUR PARENTS PLAN-
IF YOU'RE BETWEEN JOBS- YOU KNOW
THE OTHER. HERE IS COULD BE MORE
LONG TERM ON INSURANCE SO. YOUNG
PEOPLE YOU KNOW ARE COULD BE
CONNECTED TO MEDICAL CARE-
INTERMITTENTLY YOU KNOW HOW TO
HAVE A PRESCRIPTION ALREADY ON
FILE FOR THOSE MEDICATIONS IS
JUST. YOU KNOW HAVING. WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO MAKE THAT
TRADE OFF BETWEEN. THEIR OTHER
EXPENSES FOR AND HOUSING FOOD
RENT ETCETERA THAT BY BRINGING
BETTER THEIR COSTS LOWER FOR.
AFFORDABLE AND SMALL AND-
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO- YOU KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE A HEALTH PLAN
WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE PAYING-
ACCESSING MEDICATIONS THAT WAY.
SO FOR CONSUMERS YOU FOR SECOND
SOUL DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE WILL BE ON
BENEFITING FROM THE FENCE. SO AS
FAR A- THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'D BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP ON-
ON IN TERMS OF LICENSES WHAT
WHAT IT WOULD MEAN FOR
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER AND SAVINGS
. WHAT THE THAT'S THAT THAT'S MY
PROBLEM WITH THIS- YOU KNOW LIKE
I THIS IS MY SIXTH YEAR HERE AND
EVERY TIME WE SEE THE WORD TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT MEANS YOU
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER. AND IF
WE'RE HERE REQUESTING FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
I WOULD HOPE AND AGAIN HOPE IS
NOT A STRATEGY BUT WE'RE USING
THE WORD HOPE A LOT- THAT THAT
WE WOULD HAVE THOSE NUMBERS SO
THAT WHEN I ASK YOU THAT
QUESTION- WE HAVE A CONCRETE
NUMBER- WE CAN. SPEND ALL THIS
MONEY ON ASSUMPTIONS AND WITHOUT
HAVING ANY CONCRETE INFORMATION
SO WHEN YOU SAY THAT THAT THIS
WOULD HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
TRANSITION HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT I'M I'M
THINKING MY COMMUNITIES IN
BALDWIN PARK OR AND ALL MONEY
ARE THE ONES THAT. ARE ARE NOT
INSURED HAVE NOT BEEN INSURED
AND HOW WOULD BE ACCESS
PRESCRIPTION TO THIS YOU KNOW
LOW INCOME LOW ALL COST IN FULL
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR AND AGAIN-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT. SUCH AN
IMPORTANT CRITICAL CRITICAL-
MEDICATION FOR YOU KNOW THAT
THOSE FOLKS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME ANY
ANSWERS AS TO HOW MANY PEOPLE
WILL BE. BENEFIT FROM IT HI- IF
WE CAN EVEN GET- THEM INTO THE
PPM- WE'RE NOT OWNING THE
FACILITY SO WE REALLY
TECHNICALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY OVER IT WOULD. AND YOU
SAID FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS HOW
MUCH ONE VISIT IT FIFTY MINUTE
MILLION DOLLARS PERIOD IS A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN
SOME EXPERT CONTRACTOR THAT WAS
HIRED UNDER A NO BID CONTRACT IS
GOING TO SAY BY THE WAY WE NEED
ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD
BEFORE IN DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
AND IT HASN'T TURNED OUT WELL.
AND FROM WHAT I'M HEARING- YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A PLAN
YOU HAVE GREAT INFORMATION AND
AGAIN MY FAVORITE LINE TODAY IS-
CONTACT EXEMPTIONS AS OPPOSED TO
NO BID CONTRACTS. BECAUSE THAT'S
A REALLY DIFFERENT WAY OF SAYING
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY VETTING
ALL OF THESE CONTRACTORS. AND
SO. I CAN GO ON AND ON NINE I
USUALLY DO BUT I'M NOT BUT I'M
TELLING YOU THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING IS NOT ANY CONTRACT
UNTREATED. CONCRETE ANSWERS ON-
HOW MUCH MORE MONEY IS GOING TO
COST. WHO THE FOLKS TAT ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM THIS FAR
THERE'S NO ANSWER TO THE PBM
QUESTION- THERE'S NO ANSWER AS
TO HOW MUCH MORE IT'S GOING TO
TAKE IT SOUNDS GREAT BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO CREATE. CLINICAL JOBS
WITH YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE AND DO
YOU HAVE A NUMBER ON HOW MANY
JOBS IT'S GOING TO CREATE. WE
HAVE SOME. KIND OF NUMBER AND
NUMBERS ON TRACK IN TERMS OF.
HOW MANY PEOPLE I WOULD TAKE HER
TO OPERATE SUCH A FACILITY- BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT GOT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP. THANK YOU SO
AGAIN I'M HEARING THE FOLLOW UP.
YOU KNOW A CONSTANT FOLLOW UP IF
YOU'RE- I DON'T YOU KNOW LOOK.
I'M I'M- NOT- NEW TO THIS I
GUESS IS MY POINT AND THE FOLLOW
UP- AGAIN FOR ME MEANS- WE'RE
GOING TO. STALL YOU UNTIL LATER.
ON WHICH HAS HAPPENED ALREADY
MANY MANY TIMES AND SO FOR YOU
TO BE HERE ASKING FOR THIS KIND
OF MONEY. IT'S ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE ALLELES OFFICE HAVE. AMONG
OPEN TO CONCERNS OF WHO'S GOING
TO MANAGE THIS IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH AND I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO SAY IT
AGAIN IF YOU HERE. ASKING FOR
THIS KIND OF MONEY BE PREPARED
BE PREPARED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION SIMPLY YES OR NO OR
WHEN I ASK OR SOMEBODY ASKED
ABOUT DATA AND WHO'S GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS. YOU'RE ASKING
FOR FIFTY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WITH NO CONCRETE
ANSWERS SO. I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE'RE HERE
AGAIN. WITH SUCH A COMPLEX ISSUE
AND WE'RE NOT GETTING ANY
ANSWERS NONE WHATSOEVER IT'S
JUST REALLY GOOD WORDS LIKE-
CONTRACT EXEMPTIONS IT'S GOING
TO CREATE A WHOLE BUNCH OF JOBS
IT'S GONNA BENEFIT LOW INCOME
PEOPLE PEOPLE THEY CAN'T ACCESS
IT AND YOU KNOW- PEOPLE OF COLOR
I MEAN THOSE ARE THE BUZZ WORDS
THAT THAT WE HERE- SO THAT WE
CAN INVEST A WHOLE BUNCH OF
MONEY IN THE LATER WE'RE GOING
TO SAY I'M SORRY IT DIDN'T WORK
OUT AND THEN IN THE MEANTIME. WE
CAN BE USING THAT KIND OF MONEY-
FOR EXAMPLE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE- FOR DOCTOR ARAMBULA BILL-
WHERE WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING
COVERED FIFTEEN OVER BEING
COVERED I MEAN. IT'S I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A BUDGET
SURPLUS BY THAT WE'RE NOT BEING
SMART WITH THE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE NOT ALWAYS GOING TO
HAVE KIND OF THE LUXURY OF BEING
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT SUCH AMAZING
PROGRAMS AND TO HAVE A PROPOSAL
THAT REALLY HAS NO I DON'T SEE
THE VALUE IN IT BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCRETE INFORMATION
THESE ARE PIE IN THE SKY KIND OF
IDEAS WHICH I APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE THINKING OF QUOTE UNQUOTE
OUTSIDE THE BOX HOWEVER OUTSIDE
THE BOX MEANS. OUT MONEY THAT
WE'RE SPENDING ON SOMETHING THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT WORK AND IN THIS
CASE I DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
DATA THAT SAYS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO WORK SO I'LL LEAVE IT
THERE BECAUSE I KNOW I KNOW
MYSELF SO THANK YOU- BUT I DO
EXPECT THE FOLLOW UP ON- DATA
DATA ON IF I I'M A NERD WHEN IT
COMES TO DATE I'M A TEACHER AND
MY DECISIONS ARE BASED ON NOT SO
AS MUCH DATA AS YOU CAN GET ME
ON SOME OF- THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAVE TO MAYBE THE QUESTIONS
THAT I DIDN'T ASK LIKE WHO WHO'S
WE- HAVE THE ARE YOU LOOKING
INTO. HOW MANY CONTRACTORS IT
GONNA TAKE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO AND- TO ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTION EARLIER I DON'T
WANT TO. INTERRUPT- MANY TIMES
ARE UNDOCUMENTED OR UNINSURED
POPULATION COMES TO E. OURS AND
SEES PEOPLE JUST LIKE ME TO GET
THOSE PRESCRIPTIONS AND SO- DO
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL AND FRAME IT AS RISK
REWARD IF I CAN. AS THERE IS A
REWARD TOWARDS FIGURING OUT HOW
TO LOWER COST ON HOW WE CAN
ENCOURAGE BETTER FOLLOWING OF
THE DRUG REGIMENS AND DECREASE
TKIS ARE SIGNIFICANT REWARDS FOR
US BUT IT COMES WITH SIGNIFICANT
RISK AND I THINK THE L. A.
TOUCHED ON THAT WELL. THAT I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING THE
STATE'S INTERESTS WE HEARD FROM
THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE NEED
FOR US TO DEFINE MILESTONES. SO
I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
MILESTONES ARE WHAT ARE WE DOING
WHAT DETAILS DO WE HAVE- THAT
WOULD LEAD UP PRIOR TO FDA
APPROVAL WHAT ARE WE GOING TO BE
TRACKING AND FOLLOWING. PRIOR TO
ENTERING INTO ANY CONTRACTS.
CHERUB AROUND YOU I COULD START
OFF AND PASS IT ON TO RHYME
BUCKLEY- IF HE HAS ANYTHING TO
ADD- SO FOR THE U. REGARDING
MILESTONES WE HAVE- STARTED- WE
DO HAVE A PLAN ON IN TERMS OF
WHAT TYPES OF MILESTONES STATE
BANK CLUED- ALLOWING AN
APPLICATION. FOR FDA- READ
CLINICAL. NOT SERVICE
TERMINOLOGY USED FOR FDA
CLINICAL TRIALS SO WHEN- WHEN
THE STUDIES THREE BRIDGE SIR AND
POINTS OR CHIEF CERTAIN CALLS
THAT THAT THAT- THAT MEDICATION
IS- YOU KNOW MEETING THE FDA'S
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROACTIVE NESS.
BURKE PER SE D. X. CETERA AND
THEN ALSO FOR INTERCHANGE
ABILITY. THAT IT THAT THAT THE
PRODUCT COULD BE SUBSTITUTED FOR
THE BROWN PRODUCT. SO BUT THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE MILESTONES AT
LEAST ON THE DEVELOPMENT SIDE-
FOR THE MANUFACTURING SIDE
THERE'S ALSO OTHER MILESTONES
RELATED TO- SITE SELECTION AND-
FINDING- YOU KNOW I'D GET
CAPITAL EQUIPMENT PURCHASES
XCERRA SO THOSE ARE KIND OF
WHATEVER OF WHAT TYPES OF
MILESTONES THAT WE WOULD TIE-
PAYMENT TO- AND ADULT THE WAY
WHAT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IS IT
IS A GATED. OF PAYMENT OR
MILESTONE SCHEDULE. WE KNOW
ALTERNATE OVERRIDING YES
ANYTHING THAT. YEAH I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD TO THAT
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
LEAN ON OUR OUR EXPERT
COUNSELING OR INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANTS TO DEVELOP THE
DETAILS AROUND THOSE MILESTONES
AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE THOSE-
CAREFULLY DEFINED IN THE
CONTRACT AND ALSO A PLAN AS TO
HOW WE'RE GOING TO VERIFY. WITH
CERTAINTY THESE MILESTONES BEEN
THAT ALONG THE WAY. I WOULD LIKE
TO PULL IN THE L. A- TO SEE IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THE
MILESTONES. THANK YOU- YES WE
HAVE ANYTHING THOSE MILESTONES
ARE A GOOD STARTING POINT-
ESPECIALLY AGAIN UP TO THE
DEVELOPMENT STAGE. AND GETTING
THAT ACTED APPROVAL- HOWEVER
THERE'S- LIKELY GOING TO BE
SEVERAL MORE MILESTONES THAT
NEED TO BE FLUSHED OUT FOR THAT
PROCESS. I'M NOT JUST TO GET TO
THE FDA APPROVAL BUT THEN ONCE
YOU GET PAST THE FDA APPROVAL.
HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT THE
FACILITY IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE OPT OUT VOLUME. HOW DO
YOU HAVE THE- RANGE IS MADE TO
THE PLANS. YOU KNOW THE PLANNED
ARE WILLING TO PERSON THAT YOU
HAVE A BUSINESS MODEL THAT'S
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL- MANY
MANY MORE STEPS THAT NEED TO GO
IN THE PROCESS THAT- WE THINK
IT. WOULD BE CRITICAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW NOT. FUNNY
WILL GUARANTEE THAT THEY WILL
SUCCEED THROUGH ALL THOSE
MILESTONES AND SORRY THANK YOU.
ALONG THOSE LINES IF I CAN WE
HEARD HOW THE CONTRACTS CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO REVIEW AND I
OFTENTIMES LACK. TRANSPARENCY
THAT I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THE L. A. RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
GETTING A LEGAL REVIEW. FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THERE. A
RATIONALE FOR WHY WE WOULD NOT
WANT TO DO THIS IN A PUBLIC
SPACE TO ENSURE THE- MOST AMOUNT
OF TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT
THAT WE CAN HAVE. I THINK IT IT
COULD BE DONE TO AN EXTENT IN A
PUBLIC SPACE I MEAN IT WE WON'T
KNOW UNTIL WE GET INTO THE
NEGOTIATION WITH SOMEBODY'S
POTENTIAL PARTNERS- TO WHAT
DEGREE THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR
THEIR BUSINESS PLANS- YOU KNOW
CONFIDENTIAL PROTECT. PROTECT
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION THAT WAY
BUT UP I THINK THERE'S
DEFINITELY A SPACE FOR THAT- NO
WE ALREADY IN OUR PROCESS OF
LOOKING TO RETAIN. OUTSIDE
EXPERT COUNCIL WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THE AG'S
OFFICE IN EVEN JUST GETTING THE
CONSENT TO RETAIN OUTSIDE
EXPERTS. WITH THAT IN SEEING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW FROM
THE DYESS- I WOULD SAY THAT IT.
APPEARS THERE'S MUCH MORE
CONVERSATION WHICH NEEDS TO
OCCUR TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
MITIGATING ANY UNFORESEEN RISKS
AND WOULD APPRECIATE AN ABILITY
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT- ULTIMATELY
THE FINAL DECISION IS REFLECTIVE
OF ALL OF OUR CAN PUTS-
INCLUDING THE LEGISLATORS. WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE- FIVE AND I WILL THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL FOR. WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO PROPOSALS FROM DH
CS THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE%
SERVICES PANEL FIVE IS ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING
PROGRAM BCP WE HAVE ONE
PRESENTER AND G. C. COOPER WAS
THE STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR. AND
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT DH CS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR COOPER PLEASE
BEGIN YOUR- SCHIZO YOU CAN HEAR
IT. GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE A FIRST
I WANT TO STOP IN ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT IS NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH SO JUST WANTED
TO ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
FIRST TOPIC JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. I THINK GIVEN WHAT
EVERYONE HAS GONE THROUGH
THROUGH COVETED OTHER THINGS THE
IMPACT ON BOTH OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND ADULTS IS HUGE AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE INVESTMENTS
IN DISCUSSIONS AROUND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- TODAY- IN REGARDS TO THE
BRIDGE HOUSING B. C. P. THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING SIXTEEN
POSITIONS- WITH FIVE YEAR
EXPENDITURE THIRTY. OF FORTY TWO
MILLION JUST DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TO ADMINISTER THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES IMMEDIATE HOUSING
AND TREATMENT NEEDS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. IS SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
DCS ALSO REQUEST PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW FUNDS TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR AND COVERED
SYNDICATE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. JUST TO BE CLEAR. I'LL GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS AS WELL IN THE NOTE
OPEN TO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. A SO YES DH CS IS VERY
READY TO HIRE QUICKLY. A WE HAVE
BEEN ACTUALLY PREPARING ALL OF
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO HIRE AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE. I WOULD JUST NOTE
MARLEY'S PRESENT HER TEAM DOES A
REMARKABLE JOB- THAT PREPARING
FOR MANY OF THESE PIECES SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE DID IN B. H. C. I. P.
OR THE CONTINUUM. PROGRAM WE ARE
ALREADY ON ROUND THREE OF
FUNDING. A LAST YEAR AFTER
APPROVAL WITH THE BUDGET WE HAD
STAFF HIRED DOLLARS FOR ROLLING
BY AUGUST OF THAT YEAR. AS TO
THE SAME TEAM WILL BE RUNNING-
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECTS SO I'M
VERY CONFIDENT IN THEIR ABILITY
TO DO THIS. THEY HAVE LEARNED
SIGNIFICANTLY UP FROM THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUT FORWARD.
A FOR THOSE PIECES. ADDITIONALLY
YES THE DEPARTMENT DID ENGAGE
WITH A HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
EXPERTS IN REGARDS TO LEARN FOR
THIS INITIATIVE. AS WELL AS OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CALLING IN
REGARDS TO THE REAL GAPS THAT
EXIST. IN REGARDS TO WHAT WE
NEED HERE WE ALSO DID EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH IN REGARDS TO CURRENT
AND PAST SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN
REGARDS TO THE TYPES OF SERVICES
INDIVIDUALS WHO. HAVE SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS AT NEED WE
ALSO HAVE HEARD THAT WHILE THERE
HAS BEEN EXTENSIVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HOUSING DURING THE COVERED-
AND IN THE LAST FW YEARS.
ADDITIONAL SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH SPECIAL MENTAL- SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES REALLY
ARE NEEDED AND SO. I REALLY A
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IS USE FOR TO BOTH
PURCHASE INSTALL AND OPERATE
TINY HOMES. AS WELL AS THE
OPERATING FOR BRIDGE THE BOTH
ITEMS ARE INCLUDED IN THERE. AND
NOT JUST THE TINY HOMES AS AN
OPTION. AS WELL AS OTHER
SETTINGS INCLUDING RESIDENTIAL
ADULT SENIOR CARE SETTINGS. A
TINY HOMES ARE JUST ONE OF THE
OPTIONS FOR THE BRIDGE HOUSING
DOLLARS. A TO PROVIDE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO HAVE SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS. I
WOULD SAY THE EXTERNAL EXPERTISE
DH CS IS SEEKING IN OUR VARIOUS
CONTRACTS AS YOU SEE HERE. IS
REALLY THAT REAL ESTATE
ACQUISITION OF THE CONSTRUCTION
MONITORING THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
AS YOU WOULD IMAGINE- WE DO NEED
CONSULTING WE HAVE GOTTEN GREAT
CONSULTING IN THAT WORK AROUND
SOME OF THE B. H. THE I. P.
DOLLARS WE'VE DONE AND SO
WE FEEL CONFIDENT IN SOME OF
THOSE. A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL- I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT YES WELL THE
DEPARTMENT CONSULTS WITH MANY
STATE DEPARTMENTS IN REGARDS TO
THIS WE HAVE HAD HISTORICAL
SUCCESS ESPECIALLY WITH THE-
GRANTS TO HAVE BEEN ROLLING OUT
FOR THE TWO POINT TWO BILLION ON
THE B. H. THE I. P. AND FEEL
CONFIDENT WE'D BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT OUR COUNTY PARTNERS-
WITH THESE CONTRACTS AS WELL.
THAT RESULTS IN MY COMMENTS AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. I WILL BRING IT UP
TO THE DÍAS FOR ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. I WAS EXCITED TO
RECEIVE THIS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE ON GOING DISCUSSIONS. WITH
THAT WE WILL THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL NUMBER FIVE IN PANEL SIX
IS ON THE CALLIE. PCP AGAIN WE
HAVE ONE PRESENTER CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR JC COOPER. PLEASE BEGIN
OPERATE SO IDEAS YES IS
REQUESTING A HUNDRED SIX
POSITIONS. ON A HUNDRED. AND
SEVEN. POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO FURTHER SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CALLANAN
ISSUED OF- AFTER WE NEGOTIATED
AND FINISH THIS NEGOTIATIONS
WITH CMS INFO. IN DECEMBER.
OTHER A NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT
PROVISIONS PUT INTO THE STC'S
THAT WARRANTED ADDITIONAL-
STAFFING AND RESOURCES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- WHICH IS A TYPICAL
PROCESS AT THE END OF A WAIVER
NEGOTIATION IN REGARDS TO
EVALUATIONS. AND ADDITIONAL
TERMS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EXPECTS FOR US- I
WILL GO THROUGH. OF THOSE
VARIOUS INITIATIVES PER YOUR
REQUEST TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT
WITH SOME OF THOSE ARE. IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTEEN BE AN ELEVEN
FIFTEEN. WHICH I THINK YOU SEE
HERE DOMINANTLY. IS IT EXPECT A
REFLECTION OF CMS PRIORITIZING
AND THE DEPARTMENT TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU PRIORITIZING OVERSIGHT
MONITORING. OF OUR INITIATIVES
AND PROGRAMS. YOU'LL SEE A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
REGARDS TO BOTH STAFFING AT OUR
REQUEST AS WELL AS IN THE STC'S.
AROUND ACCESS ASSESSMENT ACROSS
ALL OF OUR DELIVERY SYSTEMS
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH. DIEM CO
DS WHICH IS OUR S. U. D. WEAVER.
DENTAL MANAGED CARE AND OUR
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE LINES OF
BUSINESS. ADDITIONALLY YOU'LL
SEE MEASUREMENT OF CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE ACROSS ALL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS. COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
WHICH IS THE- FOURTEEN VARIOUS
WHAT WE USED TO CALL IN LIEU OF
SERVICES THAT WERE INVESTED. IN
REGARDS TO EXTENSIVE CONTRACTS
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT ANNUAL
REPORTING- NEEDED IN ORDER TO
INCLUDING. AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF THOSE. A COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. YOU ALSO SEE INVEST FOR
THE MEDICAL LOSS RATIO REPORTING
AND REQUIREMENTS THE MONITORING
AND OVERSIGHT OF OUR DENTAL
MANAGED CARE INITIATIVE AS WELL
AS SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH. IN
THE ELEVEN FIFTEEN YOU WILL SEE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- IT TO
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
PUBLICLY AROUND THE PROVIDING
ACCESS AND TRANSFORMING HEALTH
OR WHAT WE'VE CALLED HALF. A
GRANT DOLLARS AS WELL AS
CONTINUED A REPORTING AROUND
DIEM CO DS THE NEW CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT INITIATIVE. OUR
HISTORICAL GLOBAL PAYMENT
PROGRAM WITH OUR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS AND R. C. BAST SYSTEM-
CMS DID HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAD NOT PREVIOUSLY HAD- IN
REGARDS TO OF THE UPDATE SHE
WANTED IN REGARDS THE CALUMET
BERMAN TATIAN- WE ARE MOVING
VERY SWIFTLY IN REGARDS TO ALL
THE JANUARY ONE IMPLEMENTATIONS.
I WILL NOT SOME OF THE WORK
WE'VE DONE SINCE JANUARY AND
SINCE I REPORTED PREVIOUSLY- TO
THIS- GROUP- REALLY THE PATH
DOLLARS THE DEPARTMENT HAS DONE
EXTENSIVE DEVELOPMENT IN REGARDS
TO THE PATH APPLICATION. FOR
PROVIDERS TO HAVE GRANTS
PROVIDED TO THEM- AND WE ARE
WORKING TO GET THAT INFORMATION
OUT IN MARCH RE RELEASED
GUIDANCE SPECIFICALLY TO THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE TRANSITION
DOLLARS WITHIN THAT FUNDING- SO
THAT THEY COULD UNDERSTAND HOW
TO OPERATIONALIZE THAT. WE ARE
ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF DOING A
PROCUREMENT FOR A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATORWHO WILL HELP US
DEPLOY THOSE GRANTS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
WE REPORTED PREVIOUSLY THERE'S
EXTENSIVE WORK AROUND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LOCAL COLLABORATIONS
IN THE DIRECT GRANTS TO
PROVIDERS FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO
HOLD UP AND BUILD UP. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR
CALAIS. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
WORKING VERY AGGRESSIVELY
UNIVERSE TO POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT- ARE ON- APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH WE RELEASED THE DRAFT
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY AND ROADMAP FOR
COMMENT. A BY THE PUBLIC AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING THAT
FEEDBACK WE ALSO IN THE- THE
PROCESS OF RELEASING A
PROCUREMENT FOR THE POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT SERVICE THAT
WAS FOUNDED IN BUDGET LAST YEAR-
WE ARE ALSO CONTINUING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH EMS DELAY. ON
THE JUSTICE PROPOSAL DISH B. AND
TRADITIONAL HEALERS AND NATURAL
HELPERS. AND WE ARE HOPING TO
COME TO CONCLUSION OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS HOPEFULLY BY THE
END OF JUNE OR EARLY JULY AT
THIS POINT IS WHAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY ANTICIPATING. AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU. THANK YOU I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DIESS FOR ANY
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. I WOULD LIKE
TO ONE HI I'M QUITE INTERESTED
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING OF
OUR- MANAGED CARE PLAN SO THAT
WE CAN HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE CAN
I HEAR FROM THE ITS THE- SOME OF
THE STRATEGIES. ON HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE'RE HAVING PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING OF OUR
PLANS SURE SO WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED A ROBUST GO POST GO
LIVE REPORTING MECHANISM. THE
DATE IT'S BEEN COMING IN WE'VE
BEEN COLLATING IT- THE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND REALLY WE ARE
VERY COMMITTED TO PUBLICLY
POSTING THAT SO PEOPLE CAN SEE
THE IMPLEMENTATION TRENDS THE
UTILIZATION TRENDS- OF THOSE
VARIOUS PIECES. WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTING A POST GO LIVE
SINCE WE WENT LIVE IN JANUARY OF
A PROVIDER ROUND FEEDBACK LOOP.
TALKING TO PROVIDERS DIRECTLY TO
UNDERSTAND NOT JUST WHAT WE HOPE
TO IMPLEMENT AND TO. YOU KNOW TO
DO WITH CAL AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND SO THE
TEAM HAS ACTUALLY DONE AROUND
OF. A FEEDBACK LOOPS AND WORK
SESSIONS WITH PROVIDERS WHO ARE
PROVIDING ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT OR COMMUNITY SUPPORT
AND REALLY THE INTENT THERE IS
FOR US TO LEARN EARLY. WHERE THE
ISSUES THIS IS VERY COMPLEX-
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING- NEW
RELATIONSHIPS NEW ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT JUST PULLING DATA THAT THE
PLAN SUBMIT TO US YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE TO SUBMIT A TON OF POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO US. THE DATA
SO THAT WE CAN SEE TRENDS ON THE
OUTSIDE BUT ALSO WE'RE DOING A
FEEDBACK LOOP WITH OUR PROVIDERS
REALLY TO HEAR FROM THEM WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT. WE HAVE AT
THE TEAM JUST BRIEF ME THE OTHER
DAY AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF
OPPORTUNITIES ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND SO
WILL BE MAKING SURE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD ON THOSE IN KEEPING
CLOSE EYE. I WOULD LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP NOT HERE DURING THE
HEARING BUT ON M. O. R.
SPECIFICALLY ON HOW WE CAN
ENSURE WERE HAVING THE
TRANSPARENCY. AGAIN FOR MANAGED%
CARE PLANS THAT ARE SUB
CONTRACTING I. BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO. HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT AND SO LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT HAPPY TO ENGAGE
IN A CONVERSATION. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANELS SIX
AND E WILL NOW MOVE ON THE
PANEL SEVEN WHICH WILL COVER THE
MEDICARE ALL ENTERPRISE SYSTEM.
MODERNIZATION WILL HAVE TWO
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING LAURIE WALKER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. AND CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF FISCALE AT DH CS. AND
BRIAN METZGER PRINCIPLE FISCAL
AND POLICY ANALYST WITH THE L.
A. L. WHAT'S BEGIN WITH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WALKER. AFTERNOON I IN
THIS PROPOSAL DH CS IS
REQUESTING FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS UNLIMITED TERM FUNDING
FOR CONTRACT RESOURCES. TOTAL
EXPENDITURE THIRTY IS TWENTY
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH EQUATES TO TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FEDERAL
FUNDING. FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. FOURTEEN
MILLION A TOTAL FUNDS TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND A MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL FUNDS TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. TO SUPPORT ONGOING
INFORMATION MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS- WE CURRENTLY RECEIVE
NINETY TEN ENHANCE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR MODERNIZATION OF OUR
SYSTEMS WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
MINISTERING OUR PROGRAMS. I JUST
TO CLARIFY THE NARRATIVE AMOUNT
IN THE AGENDA REPRESENTS TOTAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AND IT WAS
NOT CLEAR IN THE AGENDA OR IN
OUR B. C. P. AND THE CONTRACTOR
THIRTY MOUNTAINS THE NINETEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION. THIS
DIFFERENCE REPRESENTS THE
AUTHORITY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
FIVE POSITIONS THAT INCLUDES
SALARY BENEFITS OPERATING
EXPENDITURES AND EQUIPMENT. THIS
RESOURCE REQUEST SUPPORTS
ACTIVITIES FOR THE FOLLOWING
APPROVED PROJECTS IN THIS
FORMATION TECHNOLOGY EFFORTS
CONTINUED WORK TO DEVELOP AN
OVERALL MODERNIZATION STRATEGY
MOVE FROM THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE INTO SOLUTION DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT. FOR
THE NEW CALIFORNIA AUTOMATED
RECOVERY MANAGEMENT SOLUTION. AS
WELL AS CONTINUE WORKING THROUGH
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
FOR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
MODERNIZATION PROJECT I WORK
SPECIFICALLY ON STAGE THREE
WHICH IS PROJECT PROCUREMENT.
DHS'S APPROACH TO MODERNIZATION
UTILIZES IN AB TRIAL BASED
pMETHODOLOGY. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS ADVOWSON INTERIM REPROACH TO
PROJECT MANAGEMENT AND SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT THAT HELPS TEAMS
DELIVER. VALUE TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS FASTER AND WITH FEWER
ISSUES. TYPICALLY SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT IS DELIVERED IN WHAT
WE CALL A WATERFALL APPROACH
WHERE YOU GET ALL OF IT AT THE
VERY END. WHAT HAPPENS WITH AN
AGILE METHODOLOGY AS DTS
DELIVERS WORK IN SMALL AMOUNTS
AND CONSUMABLE INCREMENTS FOR
THE PROJECT. AND AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA THE L. A. S. SUPPORTS
REQUEST BUT RECOMMENDS THE
LEGISLATURE DOT PROVISIONAL
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES THE AGENCY HAS TO
SUBMIT ITS INITIAL STRATEGY FOR
THE MES MODERNIZATION EFFORT. BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. DMCS CURRENTLY PROVIDES
MES MODERNIZATION UPDATES DURING
QUARTERLY LEDGE BRIEFINGS AND
ANNUAL BUDGET REQUESTS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE SUFFICIENT.
AND LANGUAGE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
ALLOWING THE TYPE OF INFORMATION
NOTED IN THE ALLEY-
RECOMMENDATION TO BE PROVIDED
REGULARLY. AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE
TO PRESENT BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. HELLO BRIAN
METZGER IS THIS OKAY THAT ONE
SORRY. LET'S TRY THIS AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT- BRIAN METZGER LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE HAVE NO
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL IS NOTED BUT RECOMMEND
APPROVAL WITH PROVISIONAL BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT ITS INITIAL
STRATEGY FOR THIS EFFORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ODD MES
MODERNIZATION EFFORT WILL UPDATE
AND OR REPLACE MANY OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
THAT SUPPORT THE STATE'S MEDICAL
PROGRAM. AN INITIAL STRATEGY
WILL OUTLINE THE GOALS AND
OUTCOMES AND TARGETS FOR THIS
EFFORT PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
OPERATIONAL PROCESSES AND
WORKFLOWS DECIDE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE EFFORT
AND START TO EXPLAIN HOW ALL OF
THE PROJECTS WITHIN THIS EFFORT
WILL BE DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED. SUBMITTING THIS
DOCUMENTATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HELP TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
EFFORT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
MITIGATED AND HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE TO COMPLETE THIS EFFORT AND
AT WHAT COST. IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERS THIS
LANGUAGE TO BE POTENTIALLY
DUPLICATIVE OF CURRENT BUDGET-BILL LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
QUARTERLY MEETINGS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS UPDATES ON NEW CONTRACTS-WE THINK MODIFYING THIS LANGUAGE
TO SPECIFY THAT THE STRATEGY
DOCUMENTATION MUST BE DELIVERED
BY THE END OF THE BUDGET YEAR
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLARITY AS
THIS EFFORT MOVES FORWARD. I
WITHOUT HAVING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WE WILL
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR WHAT. THANK
YOU- FOR THE OVERVIEW ON THIS
ITEM- I'VE GAINED A LOT OF
APPRECIATION FOR HOW IMPORTANT
MODERN AND MODERNIZING
MODERNIZING OUR MEDICAID THEIR
PRICES SYMBOL MES- IS. FOR
ABILITY TO ADMINISTER THE
LARGEST MEDICAID PROGRAM IN THE
NATION SO QUESTION- CAN M. M. E.
S. B. TAKING ADVANTAGE OF TO
SUPPORT THE DATA SHARING SIDE OF
CALAMP. I LIKE THINGS LIKE
MAKING SURE THE HEALTH PLANS AND
PROVIDERS RABAL EXCHANGING USE
CLINICAL RECORDS AND CLAIMS
DATA. TO PROVIDE WHOLE PERSON
CARE FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEDICARE OUR PATIENTS. YEAH
EXCELLENT QUESTION WE DO HAVE
ARE CHEAPER AS CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER ARE AVAILABLE REMOTELY
CHRIS RECENT COULD ASSIST WITH
THE THREE. CAN WE HAVE THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR DH CS.
J. C. K. AS WELL. I GUESS WHAT
I'M WHAT I'M LOOKING AT HERE IS
CAN WE ARE WE ARE WE ABLE TO
COMBINE THESE PRIORITIES
TOGETHER THAT THINK THEY ARE.
BOTH IMPORTANT. HEY CHRIS RESEND
IT TO CONFIRMATION OFFICERED ACS
YOU GUYS HEAR ME OKAY. YEAH OKAY
SO. TO HAVE TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT IT THE MES DOES
SUPPORT THE ITEMS THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP- AND AS WE GO THROUGH
AND MODERNIZE THIS THE OVERALL
AMERIGAS WHICH IT WHICH
REPRESENTS ALL OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT SUPPORT MEDICAID INCLUDING
FOR EXAMPLE- ON THE DATA SIDE
THE WAREHOUSE OR THE DATA
WAREHOUSE AND THE RELATED
SYSTEMS THAT PROVIDE DATA- IT IT
WILL SUPPORT THAT- CAL AIM
REALLY REPRESENTS MORE OF THE
BUSINESS SIDE OF THINGS- IN THE
CHANGES FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE AND- ASSOCIATES
SYSTEM CHANGES AND SO WHEN WE
WORK ON ALL OF THIS WE TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT. AND THERE WON'T BE
OVER LACK OF EFFORT OCCURRING.
HE SAID IT CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OR
CAN YOU CAN DO IT BUT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE THERE'S A- COMMITMENT
TO ACTUALLY DOING THAT THE
REASON UP I'LL BRING IT UP IS IT
JUST SAVE IF WE'RE NOT GOING TO
COMBINE THESE ISSUES I THINK
WE'RE MISSING. A UP AN
OPPORTUNITY- I'M PRESSING ON
THIS- A LITTLE BIT. LET LEARN
OTHER STATES ARE DRAWN DOWN- IN
THOSE INCREDIBLY- GENEROUS MES
FUNDS FOR THIS TYPE OF DATA FOR
THE DATA TAPE DATA SHARING
INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORKS THAT.
COULD COULD POTENTIALLY DELIVER
SO THAT YOU CAN DO IT BUT I
DON'T I'M NOT HEARING THAT WE'RE
NECESSARILY GOING TO DO IT-
BECAUSE CAL AT SOAP AND I'VE GOT
SOME NOTES HERE SO I'M GONNA
READ THIS RATHER THAN SCREWED UP
OKAY. SO BUT- IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT CALIFORNIA. WITH FOR SOME
REASON HASN'T PURSUED THIS TYPE
OF A COMPREHENSIVE PROJECT IT
FEELS LIKE. WE DO THIS MAYBE ADD
ON LATER ON BUT NOT BUT PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER AND MY MISSING
SOMETHING THERE. I'M NOT EFFORTS
I'M NOT TAKING ISSUE WITH THE B.
C. P. I MORE TAKING I'M MORE
WANT TO KNOW IS THIS A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH OR WE
GONNA START WITH SOMETHING AND
TRY TO ADD. ADD SOMETHING ON
BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK
OUT GREAT. YES WHAT'S THE LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE STRATEGY IS
THAT WE USE THAT I'M LAURIE AND
BRIAN WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER. SO THE OVERALL STRATEGY
FOR IMPLEMENTING THESE CHANGES
ENHANCEMENTS IMPROVEMENTS- AT
TIMES MAYBE REPLACEMENT OF
SYSTEMS. IN THE END THE **** IS
ONE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
OVER TIME SO WHAT WE DELIVER. AT
THE END OF TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IS VERY IS REALLY THE
INITIAL- STRATEGY AND ROADMAP
BUT REALLY WHAT ALL OF THIS
REPRESENTS IS AN UNDERSTANDING
OF BEING STRATEGIC ABOUT HOW WE
DO MODERNIZATION OF THE SYSTEMS.
IT'S ALL BASED AND- AND IT'S ALL
BASED ON BUSINESS PRIORITIES
THAT WILL BE SET BY CAL AMY AND
THEIR EFFORTS. THAT WILL DRIVE
THE BUSINESS PRIORITIES THAT
GETS TRANSLATED INTO AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT PARTS OF
THE M. YES WE NEED TO MODERNIZE
pAND WEBER. AND SO WHEN I SAY CAN
I GUESS WHAT I MEAN IS THAT
THOSE PRIORITIES THAT GETS THAT
BY- THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING WITH MEDIC COW WILL
WILL WILL DRIVE THE ROAD MAP.
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER AND ALL OF THAT COMES
TOGETHER AND CONTINUES TO EVOLVE
OVER TIME AS THOSE BUSINESS
PRIORITIES CONTINUE TO CHANGE OR
BE UPDATED- AND SO. ALL OF THE
SO AND I DON'T KNOW THE DETAIL
IN TERMS OF THE- SPECIFICS OF
THE DATA THAT YOUR THINKING
ABOUT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. BUT IT
DOES ALL TIED TOGETHER AND WE
WILL BE WORKING ON THESE THINGS
IN FACT TO DATE IS ONE OF THE
KEY ASPECTS OF WHAT UNDERLIES
THE. ENTIRE AND THE S. AND
ALLOWS US TO BE A TO THE WORK
THAT WE PLAN TO DO TO MODERNIZE
. SO IT SO SOUNDS LIKE A FIVE
STAR SO SOUNDS LIKE YOU CAN DO
THIS BUT WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
IS. AT I'M ACTUALLY I COULD ASK
KIND OF ASKING CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE BOLDER
ABOUT THIS AND TRY TO- HE CAN DO
IT HE SAID THEY CAN DO IT YEAH
BUT CAN THE IS THERE A WILL TO
DO AND THE REASON IS A LOOK I'M
SPONSORING A NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- SHOULD. HAVE DATA
SHARED EQUITY- PACKAGE FOR MEDIC
CAL ON BEHALF OF A LARGE
COALITION OF PLANS AND PROVIDERS
AND HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGES
AND SO. A LARGE PART OF THE
PACKAGE A ISSUES AND YES TO
SUPPORT- H. I. EASE AND THE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CALAMP-
FORGET MY CARE MANAGEMENT
POPULATION HEALTH AND SO ON SO
YES WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS. IS
THERE A WILL. TO LEVERAGE. HUGE
POTENTIAL FEDERAL MATCHES IN
THIS- IN AND TAKE A BOLD STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION OR- ARE WE GONNA
JUST KIND OF BUILD THIS THING
AND LITTLE PIECES AND HOPE IT
ALL COMES TOGETHER AND FUNCTIONS
THE WAY. WE WANTED TO- SO YOU
KNOW I'D APPRECIATE IF THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY- AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS EVERYONE TO REALLY
TALK ABOUT THIS. MAYBE A BOLDER
APPROACH- THAT WE COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THINGS UP FRONT.
COMPREHENSIVELY INSTEAD OF. YOU
KNOW BUILDING THAT KIND OF AS WE
GO ALONG YEAH I THINK WOULD
CHRIS IS MENTIONING IS THERE'S
BEEN SO MANY CHANGES IN MEDICARE
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE ARE TRYING
TO USE THIS PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
LINK. CALLEVA IS A CORE
COMPONENT FOR EXAMPLE ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SIDE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS THAT PLAY IN
TWO TO THAT SIDE OF THINGS-
THROUGH THIS WORK WE'RE HOPING
TO KIND OF IDENTIFY HOW DO WE
MODERNIZE THOSE SYSTEMS SO THEY
ARE. MORE EFFICIENT SO THAT
COUNTIES ARE ENTERING INTO
MULTIPLE WAYS USING MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS TO TRACK ALL THE
DIFFERENT FUNDS WHETHER IT'S OUR
MEDIC HALLER AND THEY JUST SAY
OR THE BLOCK GRANTS THERE'S
LITERALLY DIFFERENT SYSTEMS FOR
THOSE AND SO I THINK. I THINK
THE UNDERLYING THAT IS. THE GOAL
OF WHAT CHRIS'S OUTLINING CALLIN
AS ONE OF THE LARGE OPPONENTS IN
ADDITION TO OTHER THINGS IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WILL BE A PART
OF THAT PROCESS. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT- THE POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT SERVICE THAT WAS
APPROVED IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
WILL BE SUBSTANTIALLY A HUGE
IMPROVEMENT WHICH WERE HOPING TO
LAUNCH IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WE'RE WILL BE USING ALL OF OUR
AT LEAST ADMINISTRATIVE DATA.
DATA FROM SISTER DPARTMENTS
INTO THE SYSTEM FOR PLANTS
PROVIDERS AND BENEFICIARIES TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE FULL ACCESS TO
THEIR MEDICAL SERVICES.
ULTIMATELY THE FUTURE WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO TIE INTO THAT- YOU KNOW
A CLINICAL DATA THROUGH H. I.
USE AND OTHERS ON THAT MAY HAVE
TO BE A PHASE TWO BUT IT'S IN
THE CONVERSATION OF WHAT WE WANT
TO PULL INTO. A INTO THE-THE
SERVICE IN THE FUTURE IN WE ARE
DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
THAT INITIATIVE WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROCESS AND
THAT WOULD BE A PART OF THIS
LARGER STRUCTURE. THAT CHRIS AND
HIS TEAM ARE LEADING IN REGARDS
TO HOW DO WE LEVEL OUT SOME OF
OUR SYSTEMS AND YOU KNOW ABILITY
TO PULL THAT DATA IN. YOU KNOW
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO ALL THE
RIGHT PEOPLE- AND SO HAPPY TO
KIND OF CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE BEST WAYS THAT WE
CAN MAXIMIZE THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE. ACROSS ALL OF MEDICAL. SO
SOUNDS LIKE WHEN I'M- AT THE
BOLD APPROACH I'M LOOKING FOR
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER IS GOING A.
B. FACED. POTENTIAL I WOULD
IMAGINE IT'S DEFINITELY GONNA BE
PHASE BUT I WILL DEFER TO KRISTA
IN REGARDS TO UNDERSTAND ONE OF
TRAFFIC CONCEPTUALLY LOOK
THERE'S FEDERAL FUNDING OUT
THERE WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE AS
MUCH AS WE CAN WORK AND SO WE
HAVE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH THAT FEELS LIKE WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET THAT
FUNDING A LITTLE EASIER THAN.
YOU KNOW. ADDING ON MODULES AS
WE GO FORWARD I JUST THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE I'M GOING WITH THIS
YES THAT I DON'T KNOW. THE L. A.
O. HAVE COMMENTS ON THAT YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT. YO
KNOW WHAT TOUCH THAT ONE. COME
ON PEOPLE. NO I THINK I THINK IT
SPEAKS TO OUR AND BIOMETRIC
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
AGAIN SPEAKS OUR RECOMMENDATION
ABOUT THE NEED TO DELIVER THIS
INITIAL STRATEGY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. SUCH THAT I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT. THE GOALS THE
OUTCOMES THE TARGETS FOR THIS
OVERALL PROCESS ARE. SUCH THAT
IF WE WERE TO INCLUDE OTHER
COMPONENTS. SUCH AS SAID YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT WAYS OF LOOKING
AT DATA DIFFERENT WAYS OF TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF- KIND OF. THE DATA
LED EFFORTS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
UNDERWAY. IT COULD BE DISCUSSED
AS PART OF A- OF A LARGER. KIND
OF STRATEGY DOCUMENT THAT THEY
PLAN ON HAVING AVAILABLE BY THE
END OF THE BUDGET YEAR. YEAH I
GUESS IS THE CHIP CHALLENGES I
MEAN WE OFTEN SO YOU KNOW WE
OFTEN START ON THESE INITIATIVES
AND WE DON'T COSTARRED
COLLECTING THE DATA SOON ENOUGH
OR WE DON'T SOMETIMES. OUR
PROGRAMS WE KNOW OF THAT ARE
COLLECTING DATA OR COLLECTING
DATA NOT DOING ANYTHING WITH
THAT. AND SO YOU KNOW FOR ME I'M
THINKING CAN WE NOT COLLECT THE
DATA REAL TIME USE IT AND HELP
TO- YOU KNOW MAKE THE SYSTEM
MAKE THINGS WORK IN A MORE
ROBUST AWAY. RATHER THAN GETTING
IT STARTED THEN IN DO YOU SEE
WHERE I'M GOING OR I DON'T. YEAH
I HOPE I HOPE SO I JUST. IT'S
FIVE I JUST FEEL IT JUST FEELS
MORE STRATEGIC AND IN THE LONG
RUN AND POTENTIALLY MORE-
BENEFICIAL- AS BRING. ABLE TO
ANALYZE THAT DATA AS AS WE'RE
GETTING IT RATHER THAN WAITING.
AND ADDING TO IT. ALL OF THIS
AND I'M GOING TO GET THAT MEANS
WAY LOWER. WAS SPEAKING TO AND
HER OPENING NOTES WHICH IS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY. OUR INTENT
IS TO DELIVER THIS OVER TIME AND
DO IT IN AN INCREMENTAL FASHION
WHERE WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF
BOTH THE MODERNIZE SYSTEM THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE AND ALSO THE
DATA THAT MAY BE TIED TO IT- SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ALL OF THAT. EARLY AND OFTEN AS
OPPOSED TO. WAITING FOR TEN
YEARS TO DEVELOP. A NEW SYSTEM
THAT ENCOMPASSES EVERYTHING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE. THAT
THAT SORT OF APPROACH DOESN'T
PROVIDE US VALUE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING AS LARGE
AS THE MES. WHAT APPROACH GETS
AS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DROP
BROWN'S MUCH FEDERAL FUNDING AS
WE CAN THAT'S WHAT I'M AFTER IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT ON I WILL SAY
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WITH THESE
EFFORTS RIGHT WE MAXIMIZE NINETY
TEN ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF. THIS
EVERY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN.
EIGHT AND JUST SO THAT WE'RE
CLEAR- WERE UTILIZING FEDERAL
FUNDING TO HELP SUPPORT. THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OTHER
PROJECTS IN THE STATE AND THAT
SAME WAY SO THERE IS A VERY.
GOOD EFFORTS TO MAXIMIZE THE USE
OF FEDERAL FUNDS WHERE WE CAN TO
SUPPORT. THE MES AND THE
MODERNIZATION OF THEM YES. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE CHAIR AND I WILL
FOLLOW UP JUST BECAUSE I.
BELIEVE IT WARRANTS IT EARLIER
YOU SAID THAT THE STRATEGY ON
MODERNIZATION. JUST RECENTLY
SAID THAT WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL. FUNDS THAT WE PULL
DOWN. DO WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN OR WHEN. FEDERAL MONEY IS
NOT. OR IT IS AVAILABLE FOR US.
INTO WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE.
UNDERTAKING CERTAIN PROJECTS. DO
YOU MEAN ARE WE MAKING DECISIONS
THAT'S CORRECT DO YOU MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON WHETHER OR
NOT- YOU GET IT 90% FEDERAL
MATCH DOES THAT THEN CHANGE OUR
ABILITY TO CREATE A STRATEGY.
WELL IT IT WON'T IT WON'T CHANGE
YOUR ABILITY TO CREATE THE
STRATEGY AND I WILL SAY- GETTING
FOR EXAMPLE THE NINETY TEN MATCH
FROM FROM CMS FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. ONE MORE JEWISH IT
PROJECTS. IT IS NOT NECESSARILY
CHALLENGING IT CAN BECOME
CHALLENGING WHEN WE ARE FOR
EXAMPLE TRYING TO DO A PROJECT
THAT IS BUILDING SOMETHING
THAT'S TO CLICK IT IS A BIG OF
ANOTHER PROJECT AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS A FACT- WITHIN CALIFORNIA
WINE CMS. GAVE US SPECIFIC
DIRECTION AROUND THE STATE ARMY
WELFARE SYSTEMS RIGHT CAL SAWS
AND DIRECTED US TO GET TO A
SINGLE SYSTEM RIGHT SO THEY
DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR
FUNCTIONALITY MULTIPLE TIMES ARE
DUPLICATE SYSTEMS THEY WANT PAY
ONCE. BUT AS LONG AS WE'RE
MEETING THEIR ACT THOSE SORTS OF
EXPECTATIONS GETTING NINETY TEN
FUNDING FOR THESE IT PROJECTS IS
NOT IS NOT REALLY WHERE THE
CHALLENGE LIES IT'S REALLY IN
THE DOING OF THE PROJECTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE LARGE AND
COMPLEX- AND SO. THAT THE
STRATEGY. ITSELF WON'T. ONE NEXT
. TOUCHING ON BACK BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE VISIT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BUSINESS
PRIORITIES AND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MEET THOSE AND HOW THE
SYSTEMS GET MODERNIZED. AS WE
BEGIN TO TACKLE EACH PART THAT'S
WHEN WE REALLY APPROACH THE
FUNDING BECAUSE CMS ALSO LOOKS
AT EVERY ALL OF THIS FROM A VERY
MODULAR VIEW. AND SO THEY WANT
TO BROKEN DOWN INTO PIECES AND
THEY FIND IT BASED UPON THOSE
SMALLER PIECES BUT IS THAT YEAH
BUT IF YOU HAD MORE FUNDING
COULD YOU THEN DO MORE PIECES.
DOESN'T THAT CHANGE OUR STRATEGY
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M REALLY
TRYING TO GET OUT HERE. CAN YOU
ADVANCE FASTER IF WE'RE PULLING
DOWN 90% FEDERAL MATCH AND WHY
ARE WE NOT MAXIMIZING THAT IN AN
ATTEMPT TO. HAVE THE CHANGE WE
KNOW NEEDS TO HAPPEN- SEE A
PROBLEM WITH THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS. ALL THE PROJECTS IN
THERE AND THE MES MODERNIZATION
ARE NINETY TAX. SO WE ARE
PULLING DOWN NINETY TENANTS
FUNDING IN ORDER TO SUPPORT ALL
OF THIS AND WE EXPECT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. BUT I ALSO
THINK THERE'S A CERTAIN CAPACITY
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY-
SUCCESSFULLY EXECUTE ON AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY BASED
UPON. THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING OR
THE NINETY TEN FUNDING IT'S THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
CHANGE THAT. WE ALL ARE ABLE TO
. EXECUTE AT ONE TIMEWELL WE
HAVE TO DO IT BASED UPON
BUSINESS AND PROGRAM PRIORITIES
AND SO WE'RE REALLY BILL HOLD ON
THE TECHNOLOGY SIDE RIGHT WE'RE
REALLY BEHOLDEN TO THE CHANGES
THAT. ARE REPRESENTED WHETHER
THROUGH A LAME OR OTHER YOU KNOW
PROGRAM EFFORTS- AND THE DRIVING
OF THOSE IN ORDER TO DO THIS
WORK- I DON'T THINK USING AN
ANALOGY IT SEEMS THAT YOU'RE OUT
BAND WITH FOUR OF THE CAPACITY
OF CHANGED NOW. AND THAT
INCREASED RESOURCES WOULD NOT
LEAD TOWARDS INCREASED CHANGE IS
THAT. THE CORRECT SUMMATION OF
WHAT YOU JUST SAID. I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE NECESSARILY IT IS THE
RIGHT NOW WHERE WHERE WE'RE AT
IS THAT. WE SPENT THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS BRINGING TOGETHER
VARIOUS MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
IN ORDER TO HAVE A MORE
ENTERPRISE APPROACH OR AN
APPROACH THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE BROADER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
M. S. SOME OF WHAT WE WERE
TALKING TOUCHING ONEARLIER. AND
NOW THAT WE'VE DONE THAT WORK
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO BUILD THE
STRATEGY THAT WILL REALLY HELP
US TO- ALSO BETTER UNDERSTAND
MAYBE WHAT THAT CAPACITY IS THAT
YOU'RE TOUCHING ON. AND
UNDERSTAND HOW WE WILL EXECUTE
ON ALL OF THE CHANGES IT'S A
LARGE AND COMPLEX SYSTEM TO DO
WHEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HANDLING IT IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY- AS WE HEARD
EARLIER THESE ARE AGILE BASED.
SYSTEMS WHICH MEANS IT IS TO BE
AN ITERATIVE APPROACH AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE. THE LEGISLATURE TO
PLAY AN ACTIVE ROLE IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND WANT TO UPLIFT
AND SUPPORT THE COMMENTS OF DR
WOULD HERE TONIGHT. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH ISSUE SEVEN
WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE A. OUR
STATE TO. PANEL EIGHT IS ON THE
COVERT NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ON RESUMING REGULAR
OPERATIONS BCP WILL HAVE 1% ARE
ON THIS PANEL DEPUTY DIRECTOR
LAURIE WALKER WITH DH CS PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU AT THE FCS IS
REQUESTING THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM RESOURCES EQUIVALENT TO
EIGHT POSITIONS CONTRACT
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY EQUAL TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR A TOTAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWENTY
SIX POINT TWO MILLION WHICH IS
THIRTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND. T. ONLINE THE A
PER THE ARRAY OF PROGRAM POLICY
RELATED SYSTEM CHANGES THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE DURING THE COURSE
OF THE COVETED AND PANDEMIC AND
MINIMIZE ANY POTENTIAL
DISRUPTION THAT COVERAGE TO
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE COVER
NINETEEN PHD UNWINDING IN THE
REDETERMINATION WORK THAT
COUNTIES WILL HAVE TO DO. THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INCLUDED A HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS TWO YEARS
RELATED TO COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROCESSING OF THE
REDETERMINATION CASELOAD. DCS
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ON ASSESSING
WORKLOAD FOR COUNTIES THROUGH
COUNTY SERVICE. DMCS WILL BE
EVALUATING THE RESULTS OF RECENT
COUNTY SURVEYS ON RESOURCES AND
COLLABORATE WITH C. W. T. ON
NEXT STEPS. DCS IS ALSO WORKING
WITH IT EVERY PROVIDING GUIDANCE
AND TOOLS FOR THE COUNTIES TO
ASSESS THEIR READINESS FOR THE
UNWINDING ACTIVITIES. THEY MUST
UNDERTAKE WHILE STILL ADDRESSING
INCOMING APPLICATIONS AND
ONGOING MANAGEMENT OF EXISTING
CASES. THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL
GIVES YES TAKING A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO KEEP THIS POPULATION
INSURED BY PROCURING AN ANNEX AN
EXPERIENCED VENDOR TO EDUCATE
AND RAISE AWARENESS FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. TO UPDATE THEIR
CONTACT INFORMATION WITH THEIR
COUNTIES. AND TO ALSO MAKE AWARE
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THEIR
ELIGIBILITY TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEIR NON RESPONSIVE TO REQUESTS
FROM THE COUNTY'S REGARDING
RENEWALS FUNDS TO COVER PHD AND
- THE VENERABLE DESIGN
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE OUTREACH
MATERIALS IN LETTERS TO BE
MAILED TO OUR APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
BENEFICIARIES. AND TO
DISSEMINATE THESE MATERIALS TO
OUR MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
COUNTIES ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS. THE
PARTICULAR VENDOR WILL AUGMENT
THE RECENTLY LAUNCHED PHASE
COMMUNICATION CAMPAIGN TO REACH
BENEFICIARIES WITH IMPORTANT
MESSAGES. ACROSS MULTIPLE
CHANNELS WITH TRUSTED PARTNERS
DHS CALLS COVERAGE INVESTORS.
THIS CALL THE NINETEEN PHD
ONLINE COMMUNICATION AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN WILL ROLL OUT
IN TWO PHASES TO PRIORITIZE AND
SEQUENCE STRATEGIES TACTICS AND
MESSAGES ACROSS THE STATE TO
PREPARE FOR RESUMPTION OF NORMAL
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY OPERATIONS.
PHASE ONE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY IS
TO ENCOURAGE BENEFICIARIES TO
PROVIDE UPDATED CONTACT
INFORMATION INCLUDING NAME
ADDRESS PHONE NUMBER AND EMAIL
SO THE COUNTY CAN CONTACT THEM.
WITH IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
KEEPING THEIR MANA CAL. THE
OUTREACH TOOLKIT IS AVAILABLE
NOW ON DHS'S WEBSITE FOR
DOWNLOAD. IN PHASE TWO DH CS
WILL CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE ME-
BENEFICIARIES TO UPDATE THEIR
CONTACT INFORMATION AS WELL AS
REPORT ANY CHANGES IN THEIR
PERSONAL CIRCUMSTANCES. CHECK
THEIR MAIL FOR UPCOMING RENEWAL
PACKETS. AND SHOULD THE COUNTY
BE UNABLE TO COMPLETE THE
RENEWAL USING INFORMATION
ALREADY AVAILABLE TO THEM TO
COMPLETE AND TO HAVE WITHOUT
HAVING TO CONTACT THE
BENEFICIARY. THIS PHASE WILL
BEGIN SIXTY DAYS PRIOR TO THE
END OF THE COVERT PEACHY. A FACE
TO OUR REACH TOOK IT WILL ALSO
BE RELEASED TO ASSIST STATE AND
COUNTY EFFORTS. DSDS IS ALSO
ASSESSING FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY IS
THAT CAN BE LEVERAGED TO HELP
ASSIST WITH RENEWALS. TO
MINIMIZE COVERAGE LOSS THIS
FLEXIBILITIES WERE OUTLINED IN
FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND ROSALIE'S
BACK IN MARCH REGARDING
UNWINDING ACTIVITIES AND STEPS
STATES CAN TAKE TO HELP PROMOTE
CONTINUITY OF COVERAGE AND
MINIMIZE COVERAGE LOSSES DURING
THE TERMINATION PROCESS. THAT'S
IT HAPPY TO ANSWERING. THANK YOU
I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY MEMBER
QUESTIONS I WILL START IF I CAN-
I WAS MOVED ON PAGE FIFTY SEVEN
OF THE AGENDA- THAT. IT STATES
THAT THE PENDING CASE. ACTIONS
FOR REDETERMINATION WILL BECOME
PARABLE TO IMPLEMENTING THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN TERMS OF
WORKLOAD. AND DOES WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU ARE APPROPRIATELY
RESOURCE. WITH THE- COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION TO
DO THIS WORK AND WE HEARD IT WAS
A HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
I BELIEVE. THAT THE COUNTIES
RECEIVED LAST YEAR IT FOR
ESTIMATING THERE ARE THREE
MILLION BENEFICIARIES WHO COULD
GO INTO THE REDETERMINATION
PROCESS. IS FIFTY DOLLARS
ANOTHER PER BENEFICIARY FOR US
TO. B. ENSURING THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN HELP HOW DO WE
ENSURE SO ALL WE ARE AT THE
RIGHT NUMBER STARTED- I'LL START
AND THEN RENEE MULLIN A BILL TO
JUMP INSIDE ACTUALLY IF A
CORRECT THAT WE WILL ACTUALLY
HAVE TO DO. REDETERMINATION ON
ALL FOURTEEN POINT WHAT NOW IS
SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE- IN THE
PROGRAM- WE ARE OUR CURRENT EX
PARTE PERCENT IS AROUND 36%
ACTUALLY DECREASED WITH COVETED-
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY
THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY ALLOW US
TO INCREASE THAT. STILL HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WHAT THOSE
WOULD LOOK LIKE WE PLAN ON
RELEASING IN MID MAY-
COMPREHENSIVE ON WINDING
APPROACH- FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE ARE
APPROACHING THIS- ESSENTIALLY SO
WE WOULD WANT TO GET AS MANY AS
WE CAN THROUGH THAT EXPERT TAKE
PROCESS. WITHOUT HAVING TO THEN
DO REDETERMINATION- I THINK- WE
ARE ANTICIPATING THAT ANYWHERE
FROM TWO TO THREE MILLION THOUGH
CURRENTLY WITHIN IT WILL RESULT
IN NOT BEING- POTENTIALLY
STAYING ON THE PROGRAM. I DO TOO
AT SOME POINT DEPENDING ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDS WE
GET HAVE ANYWHERE YOU KNOW AS A
LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WILL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH BUT AS YOU
KNOW IT BUT SIZEABLE NUMBER THAT
WE THINK WON'T MOVE FORWARD- FOR
NUMBER OF REASONS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD AT THREE- IN ROMANS NOT
TAKE PLACE AT THE POINT OF
TOUCH- THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF YEARS WITHOUT RE
DETERMINING INCOME AND OTHER
PIECES. I WE ALSO KNOW
SIGNIFICAN NUMBER HAVE EITHER
HAD HEALTH COVERAGE ALREADY- AS
WE'VE HAD THAT INFORMATION AS
WELL SO I THINK WE DO ANTICIPATE
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT OVERTIME
OVER THE FULL TWELVE PLUS AT THE
WE FOURTEEN TOTAL- MONTHS A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL
REDUCTION IN THE CURRENT CASE
LAW THAT WE HAVE. WE HAVE SAFE.
IN REAL. TO BE UPDATING US ON
WHETHER OR THE COUNTIES ARE
APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE. I JUST
HAVE CONCERNS WHEN THERE ARE. SO
MANY. PATIENTS POTENTIALLY WHO
COULD LOSE THEIR INSURANCE THIS
NEXT YEAR. THE WE'RE DOING ALL
WE CAN IN ADVANCE YEAH I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR WHAT THAT STRATEGY
OR PLAN LOOKS LIKE SO- WE
ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO SEEK AN
APPROVED. I GOT APPROVAL FROM
CMS DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
TOUCH EACH APPLICATION THREE
TIMES WE WILL ONLY HAVE TO TOUCH
IT ONCE FOR THE PURPOSES OF ID
WHICH IS A HUGE DEAL BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THE WORKLOAD WOULD
HAVE BEEN. SUBSTANTIAL FOR THE
COUNTIES- WE ORIGINALLY DID THE
ESTIMATE KNOWING THAT. WE WOULD
HAVE TO DO ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO
TWO PLUS TOUCHES AND SO I
CURRENTLY WORK CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COUNTIES ON WHAT IS
THAT RIGHT AMOUNT- YOU KNOW. IN
OUR TOUCH RENEE COULD PROBABLY
TALK MORE IF SHE'S AVAILABLE IN
REGARDS TO HOW DO WE- USE
TYPICAL STANDARD METHODOLOGIES
FOR TOUCHES IN REGARDS TO HOW WE
ESTIMATE THE COUNTY WORK BASED
ON KIND OF. THE WITH A CASE
STUDY AND OR TIME STUDY INTO
THOSE PIECES. SO I THINK THOSE
ARE THE BIGGEST PIECES THE OTHER
THING IS- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS X. EXPECTING A STANDARDIZED
REPORT TO THEM AS WELL- WE WILL
ALSO HAVE A STATE. LOOK AT THAT
WHAT DOES THIS LOOK LIKE EVERY
SINGLE MONTH WHICH WILL INCLUDE.
WHAT IS OUR PERCENT OF EX PARTE
HOW MANY RENEWALS ARE OUT HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN COMPLETED AND HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN DISTANT ROLLED.
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN BETA TESTING
THE REPORTS ALREADY- IN
ANTICIPATION OF WHEN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND SO THAT WE
CAN BE VERY TIMELY WITH THAT
REPORTING AND BE TRANSPARENT TO
WHERE WE'RE SEEING PEOPLE. MAYBE
NOT RESPOND SO WE ARE TRYING TO
BE PROACTIVE IN THAT WAY. I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF WE COULD
HAVE COUNTY LEVEL DATA AS WELL. HAVE THE POTENTIAL THAN TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR COUNTIES
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO. WORK
TOWARDS THAT GOAL OF MAKING SURE
WE CAN COMPLETE ALL THE RE TO
TERMINATIONS- WITHOUT- WITH AS-
MINIMAL AMOUNTS OF DISRUPTIONS
AS POSSIBLE. WITHOUT I WILL
THANK VERY MUCH ISSUE EIGHT AND
WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NOT.
PANEL NINE IS ON THE MANAGED
CARE PLAN COMPLIANCE AND
OVERSIGHT PROGRAM B. C. P. AGAIN
OUR PANELISTS LAURIE WALKER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER WITH DH CS
THREE PLEASE. THE FCF IS
REQUESTING FOURTEEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY A THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS ONE
POINT IX MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE
EXTENSIVE AMBLED NEW CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS AND EXPECTATIONS.
OF THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS THAT ARE EFFECTIVE JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS NEW
MANAGEMENT NEW MANAGED CARE PLAN
CONTRACTING POSE A SIGNIFICANT
NEW AND ENHANCED OBLIGATIONS ON
ON MANAGED CARE PLANS. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT MUST ENFORCE. THE
POSITIONS OF EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY REQUESTED ARE TO
MONITOR OVERSEE AND HOLD MC
PEACE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS THAT
ULTIMATELY RESULT. FROM THE
PROCUREMENT EFFORTS LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES FEDERAL CHANGES OF OTHER
POLICY CHANGES AFFECTING THE
MEDICAL POPULATION. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT DCF HAVE RESOURCES
AND STAFF TO COMPLETE THIS WORK
FLOW. FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO BE
READY FOR THEM NEEDED ROBUST
COMPLIANCE AND OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS IN TIME FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. WE NEED TO INITIATE
EFFORTS BEGINNING IN JULY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF ENHANCED
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CONTRACTS
INCLUDE CONTRACTUAL COMPLIANCE
NOT JUST WITH THE PRIME PLAN
WITHIN DHS HOLD THE CONTRACT.
BUT ALSO EXPLICITLY REQUIRED
CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS TO FLOW
DOWN TO SUBCONTRACTORS. AND
DOWNSTREAM CONTRACTORS WHERE
APPLICABLE. THEY'LL BE
ADDITIONAL REPORTING AND
DELIVERABLES MC PEACE MUST
SUBMIT TO DH CS FOR REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. ANOTHER CONTRACTOR
REQUIREMENT FOR. THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO REPORT ON THEIR
DELEGATED ARRANGEMENT ON THE
COMPLIANCE AND DELEGATION
OVERSIGHT PLAN. THIS
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE DCS HAS A
FULL VIEW OF DELEGATION
ARRANGEMENTS FOR. THAT ARE
CONTRACTING MINSI PIECE HAVE
WITH THE OTHER ENTITIES THAT
PROVIDE CARE AND SERVICES TO THE
MEDICAL MEMBERS. THIS IS A NEW
REQUIREMENT DHS ON THE TO
ESTABLISH PROCESSES TO EVALUATE
THE SUBMISSIONS AND MONITOR
CHANGES OVER TIME. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS THE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR CONTRACT WILL REQUIRE HIM
SHE PIECE TO HAVE MEMORANDA OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS SUCH AS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES. THE SEMI USEFUL
INCLUDE NEW COMPONENTS SUCH AS
QUARTERLY REPORTING CONFLICT
RESOLUTION PROCESSES BETWEEN
I'M- YOU PARTY'S ANNUAL
SUBMISSION. DFAS WILL NEED TO
DEVELOP REPORTING TOOLS IN ORDER
TO REVIEW AND ASSESS COMPLIANCE
ISSUE GUIDANCE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND ENFORCE CORRECTIVE
ACTION WHEN COMPLIANCE IS NOT
MET. THESE NEW CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS ALSO REQUIRED EACH
DH CS TO SET UP AND MODIFY
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. AS WELL AS RAMP UP
FOR AN INCREASE IN AUDIT
INVESTIGATION ACTIVITY. LEGAL
ACTIVITY PERTAINING TO
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS ADVERSE
ACTIONS SANCTIONS A RECRUITMENT
. AND THAT'S IT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR
ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS UP I WILL
BEGIN IF I CAN- I'M GONNA START
IF I CAN- WITH THE RECENT FINDS
THAT WE HAD ON L. A. CARES AS A
BACKDROP- IN LIGHT OF US HAVING
THE LARGEST FINDS WE'VE EVER.
HAD ON THE MANAGED CARE PLAN.
DOES THE AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT WE
HAVE FROM THE STATE- PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT- OVERSIGHT OVER THESE
MANAGED CARE PLANS HOW DID WE
DETERMINE THIS WAS THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT FOR US TO-
RESOURCE WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THIS IS FORWARD LOOKING I'M
GOING TO BE AFTER JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WITH THEIR
NEW CONTRACTS AND COLLEEN- STILL
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
HAVE THAT OVERSIGHT. I CAN
RESPOND TO THAT SO I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING WE- WE HAVE
EXISTING STAFF AND THEN WE LAST
YEAR YOU GUYS OF FUNDED US AND
STAFF FOR THIS WORK AS WE
FINALIZED THE PROCUREMENT WE
IDENTIFIED THAT WITH THE ASK
LAST YEAR WE DIDN'T PROBABLY ASK
FOR THE ROBUST LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT THAT WE ACTUALLY PUT
INTO THE PROCUREMENT. ESPECIALLY
NOW THAT WE'RE GOING DOWN FOR
MANY THINGS ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THE DELEGATED LEVEL AND IN IN
ADDITION TO THE EXTENSIVE STUFF
PRIME PLANS WILL HAVE TO SUBMIT
TO US THAT THE DELEGATED LEVEL
WE NEED STAFF WHO CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE IT YOUR
POINT EARLIER IF YOU WE JUST
RECEIVED IT AND FILE IT DON'T
ACT ON IT DIDN'T THEN WHY ASK
FOR IT AND SO. I WE ARE ACTUALLY
DOING A SOUP TO NUTS REVIEW OF
OUR FULL OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING OF OUR MANAGED CARE
PLANS- TO MAKE SURE THAT DATA
COMING IN IS BEING ANALYZED AND
ACTED UPON- IN MAKING A NUMBER
OF CHANGES THAT WILL TAKE TIME
FOR US TO IMPLEMENT- BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE RIGHT CHECKS AND BALANCES IN
PLACE THAT WE'RE ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS- WE'RE ALSO IN
LIGHT OF. THE ALLEY CARE I DON'T
EVEN LOOKING AT OUR AUDITING
TOOL DO WE NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS OR EVEN CHANGES TO
THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF ITEMS
FIND AS YOU SEE ON OUR WEBSITE
NAY AUDITS OF WHERE WE ERE ABLE
TO SUCCESSFULLY IDENTIFY A SOME
OF THESE DEFICIENCIES AND ACT ON
THEM- BUT WE CONSTANTLY ARE
LOOKING AT THAT EVALUATING THAT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY THINGS EARLIER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE NOT PUTTING
BENEFICIARIES AND HARM- WE HEARD
ABOUT HELP. PREVENTION IS THE
BEST MEDICINE AND ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE A CONTRACT THAT WE CAN
ENFORCE. WITH THESE MANAGED CARE
PLANS SIMILARLY WILL. BEST
EMPOWER US TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE NEED ON
THE PLANTS- I WILL STATE THAT I
FOUND IT DEEPLY TROUBLING TO
HEAR FROM THE CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER FROM LA CARES. ABOUT
WHAT THEIR FEELINGS ARE TOWARDS
OUR STATE LAWS. IN THIS AREA.
AND BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO. DRIVE THAT LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S NECESSARY
SO WE CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THESE CONTRACTS- APPRECIATE THE-
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY AND I WILL
THANK VERY MUCH THE PANEL ON
ISSUE NINE AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO. HE HAD. PANEL TEN IS
ON THE OPIOID SETTLEMENTS FUND
OVERSIGHT AND THE STATE DIRECTED
PROGRAMS PCP WE WILL HAVE ONE
PRESENTER G. C. COOPER STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT DH CS PLEASE BEGIN
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
DH CS IS REQUESTING ELEVEN
POSITIONS AND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF THIRTY THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS- OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS- IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO SUPPORT THE
OVERSIGHT OF A TWO OF
CALIFORNIANS PROVISIONS OF THE
NATIONAL OPIOID SETTLEMENT. I TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS IN
THE AGENDA OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WILL
STILL RETAIN- OVER FORTY MILLION
OF THE OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS
TO CONDUCT A STATEWIDE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN REGARDING FAT AND ALL
WE JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
THE ONLY ITEM SHIFTING TO DH CS
OF FROM PUBLIC HEALTH IS THE
SHATTERPROOF ACTIVITIES OR
WHAT'S CALLED ATLAS AS I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT SO AT THE
REQUEST INCLUDES A SHIFT FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH THE DCS FOR NINE
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME FUNDS
OVER THREE YEARS- THAT WERE
INCLUDED AT THIS HAS TO DO WITH
THE LAUNCH OF THE SHATTERPROOF
ADDICTION TREATMENT LOCATOR
ASSESSMENT AND STANDARDS.
PLATFORM ALSO KNOWN AS ATLAS.
THAT WAS INCLUDED IT ALSO COMES
WITH AN OUTREACH CAMPAIGN THAT
SPECIFICALLY TIED TO ATLAS WHICH
IS WHY BOTH GET TOGETHER. OVER
BEING TRANSFERRED TO D. H. C. S.
D. H. C. S. RT HAD A CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP IN CONTRACT OF WITH
SHATTERPROOF. WE HAD BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM IN REGARDS TO
OUR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROGRAM AND HOW WE CAN GET
BETTER INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
MEDIC CAL. YOU KNOW A
BENEFICIARIES IN REGARDS TO YOU-
THE FACILITY LOCATION AND THE
QUALITY OF THOSE FACILITIES AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE ULTIMATELY MADE
THE TRANSITION OVER TO ARE
RECOMMENDING THE TRANSITION OVER
TO DH CS. SO WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE IN REGARDS
TO HOW DH CS PLANS TO SUPPORT
INNOVATION IN PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE. A
USE ADDICTION AND OVERDOSE- YOU
KNOW DH CS INTENDS TO REALLY
CONTINUE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
US IN THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
IN REGARDS TO UTILIZATION OF THE
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS. WE
CALIFORNIA BROADLY HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN REGARD TO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES. WE WERE
THE FIRST IN THE NATION AS YOU
ALL KNOW IN REGARDS EVEN MOVING
FORWARD WITH AN STD WAIVER WHICH
GREATLY IS CONTINUING TO BUILD
OUR CONTINUE- IN A ROBUST
SYSTEM- WE HAVE BEEN A LEAD ON.
A MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
EXPANSION ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
BRIDGE PROGRAM WITH AN EMERGENCY
ROOMS IN CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS
TO THOSE SERVICES. WE HAVE BEEN
LEADING THE NATION IN REGARDS TO
MET- MATT IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SETTINGS AS WELL AS THE-
NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION AS MANY
OTHER PROJECTS WE PLAN TO LEAN
ON THOSE. LEARNINGS TO BE ABLE%
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A
FOOTPRINT IN THE SPACE- AND THEN
LASTLY. IN REGARDS TO HOW WILL
THE ACS MEDS A MEASURE PROGRESS
IN REGARDS TO YOU- THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS. IT MANY OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SETTLEMENT
BUT ONE OR BOTH MOST IMPORTANT
IS AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO-
COLLATE. BASED ON ALL OF THE
COUNTIES AND CITIES REPORTING TO
THE DEPARTMENT REGARDS TO THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS. AS WELL AS
THE STATE'S USE OF THOSE FUNDS
WHICH WOULD BE POST PUBLICLY
POSTED AN AVAILABLE. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY YOU MAY. I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS I WILL KEEP IT HERE AT
THE CHAIR- VERY ENCOURAGED TO
SEE THE SETTLEMENT FUNDS HELPING
US TO ADDRESS THE OVERDOSE
CRISIS TO- FOR ME TO SEE THAT WE
ARE HAVING THREE TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF OVERDOSES FROM WHEN I-WAS PRACTICING MEDICINE. IS
DIFFICULT TO ACCEPT BASED ON THE
VOLUME I SAW BACK THEN AND NO
THERE'S MUCH MORE WE CAN DO WHAT
I WANT TO FOCUS A LITTLE BIT ON
THE PREVENTION SIDE IF I CAN- I
DIDN'T HEAR. OF PROPOSAL THAT
WILL HELP US TO ADDRESS
PILFERING- A POWERFUL ON RAMPS
WHERE CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
ARE GAINING ACCESS TO. WOOD
MEDICATIONS BECAUSE THE
PRESCRIPTION BOTTLES OR VIALS
ARE NOT LOCKABLE. IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR US TO USE OPIOIDS SETTLEMENT
FUNDS ON SOMETHING SIMILAR TO-
LOCKABLE PILL VIALS AS A MEANS
TO PREVENTION- AND HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP IF WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION OFFLINE AS WELL
SURE SO- IN BOTH OF THE
SETTLEMENT THERE'S A CLEAR LIST
OF THINGS THAT THE FUNDS CAN AND
CAN'T BE USED FOR SO I WOULD
NEED TO GO BACK AND CONSULT WITH
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT ON THAT
WAS MADE TO SEE IF THAT FALLS
WITHIN BOUNDARIES OF WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE. A SOMETHING
FUNDS COULD BE USED TO WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
ONE IS THE AUTHOR OF A BILL FOR
THE SECOND TWO YEAR NOW IN THIS
SPACE WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP
AND FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN DIRECT
RESOURCES- THANK YOU I WILL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PANEL TEN WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PANEL ELEVEN.
WHICH IS OUR FINAL PANEL TODAY.
AND AN SSUE TO BE HEARD TODAY
IS GOING TO BE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DATA SCIENCE AND IN
FOR ME. INFORMATIK ONYX
FRAMEWORK B. C. P. FROM CDPH.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. R. EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I DAY
NO MORE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS CHIEF DATA OFFICER
AND CALIFORNIA STATE REGISTRAR.
IT CANNOT BE OVERSTATED THAT THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC EXPOSE
SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN THE ABILITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM TO RESPOND RAPIDLY.
EQUITABLY AND SUSTAINABLY TO
SUCH AN OVERWHELMING EVENTS.
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATING THE NEED
FOR INCREASED INVESTMENT IN CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES. TO BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THESE GAPS CDPH
FORMED A SERIES OF FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKGROUPS.
SUPPORTED BY AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE INCLUDING A
GROUP FOCUSED ON DATA SCIENCE
ANALYTICS AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. THIS WORKERS IN BODY
TO COMMITMENT OF COLLABORATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
IDENTIFICATION OF KEY
INVESTMENTS IN CORE CROSSCUTTING
DATA SCIENCE AND IT FOCUSED
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS THAT
WOULD MAKE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
IN ACHIEVING THE OVERALL VISION.
OF POPULATION HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
. THE DAYTON TECHNOLOGY
WORKGROUP INCLUDED IN DEPTH
DISCUSSIONS WITH A BROAD RANGE
OF STAKEHOLDERS. CITY COUNTY AND
STATEWIDE SURVEYS IN A SERIES OF
EXPERT INTERVIEWS. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT EMERGED
FOCUSED ON THE INVESTMENTS
NEEDED IN CORE DATA TECHNOLOGY
IF. CAPABILITIES BOTH RECENT
CHALLENGES AND FORWARD THINKING
STRATEGIES TO PREPARE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS RESIDENTS
FOR A HEALTHIER FUTURE. THE
WORKER RECOGNIZE THAT IT WAS
ESSENTIAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH DATA
pAND TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS TO SHIP
FROM A CATEGORICAL IN CASE BASED
APPROACH TO A FLEXIBLE EGO
SOCIAL LIFE COURSE MODEL THAT
EVENTS ACTUALLY IN EVERY
COMPONENT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. THE GOAL FOR THE
INVESTMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
ANALYTICS IS TO TRANSFORM PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA SYSTEMS. BEING BASED
ONLY AND RETROSPECTIVE DATA AND
HEALTH PROMOTION TO PREDICTIVE
PLANS AND ACTIONS INCLUDING
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
EMPHASIZE EQUITY. PREVENTION AND
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. ASSOCIATED CO BENEFITS
OF THESE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
IMPROVED INFORMATION SYSTEMS
THAT WILL INFORM EFFORTS BY THE
HEALTH CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING IN PREVENTION AND EQUITY
. THE DEPARTMENT INITIATIVE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THIS PCP IN
ENABLE ACHIEVEMENT OF THE
AFOREMENTIONED GOALS INCOME
BENEFITS BY FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS INCREASED
COMMUNICATION AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND A COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT. TO
OPTIMALLY ACHIEVED ALL OF THESE
ACTORS INVESTMENT IN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DATA SCIENCE AND
INFORMATICS IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR INVESTMENT
IN IT DATA SCIENCE AND
INFORMATICS FORM THE BASIS FOR
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH B. C.
P. AND ARE THE FOCUS FOR TODAY'S
DISCUSSION. OR OUTCOME OF THIS
IS THE P. TO SHIFT FROM THE
CURRENT SILO PROGRAMMATIC
SYSTEMS. THAT NEED TO COMMENCE
OUR DECISIONS TO EXPANDED DATA
ACCESS ENABLING ADVANCED PUBLIC
HEALTH ANALYTICS FOR CDPH AND
ITS PARTNERS. CHIAPA OUTPUTS AND
OUTCOMES FOR THIS VCP INCLUDE A
GOVERNANCE FRAMEWORK FOR REVIEW
AND PRIORITIZATION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA INITIATIVES.
COMPREHENSIVE IT INVESTMENTS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS SHARE
DATA STANDARDS BASED IN
INFORMATICS SCIENCE WITH AN
ENTERPRISE LENDS THAT MOVES AWAY
FROM SILETZ SOLUTIONS. PROVIDING
ACCESS TO THE RIGHT PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA TO INFORM TIMELY
DECISION INTELLIGENCE OF THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. INTO
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY BASED
ACIONS BY LEVERAGING NEW DATA
INSIGHTS STUDENTS THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU DEAR. UNDER SELDOM THE
ACTING CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER
AT DH CS. AND I'LL BE SPEAKING
TO THE I. T. PORTION. S. B. C.
P. WE GOT THIRTEEN THE RESOURCES
THAT WILL BUILD ON THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK SET UP FOR INDEPENDENT
IN MATURITY CALIFORNIA. THE
CELTS TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MOVE TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE
SCALABLE AGILE AND SUSTAINABLE.
ADDITIONALLY THESE RESOURCES
REQUESTED IN THIS P. C. P. WELL
ALLOW US TO INVEST IN CRITICAL
AREAS THAT STRIP IN THE CAPACITY
OF FINANCIAL CAPABILITIES NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN AND SUPPORT
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS ESSENTIAL.
FOR DRESSING EXISTING EMERGING
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS.
STRUCTURATION EFFORTS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS WILL FOCUS ON
IMPROVING RESPONSIVENESS TO
EMERGENCIES AND ACCOMPLICES
CENTRAL FUNCTIONS ARTICLE. TO
REDUCING POP DISPARITIES AMONG
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. ACROSS
THE STATE THROUGH. DATA TRANSFER
ME OF INFRASTRUCTURE ACQUISITION
AND INTEGRATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA FOR MEANINGFUL INSIGHTS.
LEVERAGING PUBLIC STATEMENT
LEVERAGING PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS
TWO EIGHTY INCH- ACTIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISIONS AT ALL LEVELS
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE MUST ADDRESS
FOUR KEY AREAS- CULTURE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE RIGHT PLACE THE
RIGHT SKILLSETS WORKING TO BUILD
A CULTURE ADVERSITY INCLUSION
AND TRANSFORMATION. DECISION
INTELLIGENCE UTILIZING NEXT
GENERATION TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE MACHINE
LEARNING AND PREDICTIVE
ANALYTICS TO BECOME A LEADER IN
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA SCIENCE.
WITHIN STATE AND LOCAL SECTORS
KNOWING WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
RIGHT DECISIONS WITH THE RIGHT
DATA. IN THE RIGHT PLACE AT THE
RIGHT TIME. DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION USING DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES TO TRANSPORT
EXISTING MANUAL BUSINESS
PROCESSES AND SERVICES. OR
CREATE NEW ONES TO MEET EVOLVING
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDSAND
EXPECTATIONS WE STRIVE SCALABLE
ACCESSIBLE AUTOMATED SOURCES OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE.
DATA INFORMATION COLLECTED. UP
STUDENTS INFORMATION COLLECTION
INSEMINATION STATEWIDE. FUNDING
SECURE STABLE SECURE SUSTAINABLE
SECURE SUSTAINABILITY LONG TERM
STRATEGIES ROADMAPS AND FUNDING
PLANTS THAT WILL EIGHT MATURING
OPERATIONAL MODEL TO BETTER
ALIGN WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SERVICE DECISION THE VISION I
TST AND CAL AND CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS CHOOSE THE- REQUEST
THIRTY THREE POSITIONS AT THIRTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THIRTY THREE POSITIONS IN
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. EMILY
THEREAFTER FROM GENERAL FUND.
THIS PCP PROPOSES FOUNDATIONAL
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY DATA
SCIENCE AND INFORMATICS
INITIATIVES RIGHT YES TEACHES
YOU TO. ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK
FOR DEVELOPING AND EVOLVING
RESPONSE IT OVER ARCHING DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION STRATEGY AND
ROADMAP SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
PLANNING ACTIVITIES IN A CENTRAL
PROJECTS TO THE FUTURE. PUBLIC
HEALTH MISSION VISION AND GOALS.
IN THE BILL FLEX DYNAMIC IN
REASONABLE BACKBONE FOR THE
ROBUST PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
FUNCTIONS AND SERVICES.
ARCHITECT ATION OF DATA TO
BETTER ENABLE PUBLIC HEALTH
ANALYSIS IN HEREFORD ELEGY THAT
WILL PROVIDE ENHANCED ACCESS TO
BETTER DATA. LEADING TO BETTER
INFORMATION IN DEVELOPING DATA
GOVERNANCE DEVELOPING A DATA
GOVERNANCE FOR WHICH WILL ABLE.
IT'S AN OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES
COMPLIANCE EQUALITY IN DECISION
MAKING. IT FUNDING TO DEVELOP.
FOR BUILDING ENTERPRISE
ANALYTICS SOLUTIONS TO COMPLEX
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEMS THIS
INCLUDES SHERRY. SCHERING MARC
IT. SIX SHARING MODELING AND
TRANSFORMATION OF DATA INTO
USABLE INFORMATION KEEP PUBLIC
HEALTH USE CASES THIS PROCESS
WILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
DATA FOR LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS ANOTHER SECOND.
THANK YOU JOHN AS JOHN NOTED
WELL CDPH DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS
DELIVERING LARGE SCALE RAPIDLY
DEPLOYED COMPLEX I. T. SOLUTIONS
TO SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO THE CREDIT
NINETEENTH ENDEMIC. INVESTMENTS
ARE STILL NEEDED TO MODERNIZE
SUSTAIN THIS TRANSFORMATION OF
OUR IT AND DATA SITES
WOULD SUPPORT INTEGRATIVE
APPROACH USING THE FOLLOWING.
AND PROCESS REPLANNING.
REPLANNING PHASE CURRENTLY
INCLUDES CONDUCTING
SUSTAINABILITY ASIDE. POST CODE
REVIEWS I T. NEED TRANSFORMATION
SYSTEM CAPABILITY ANALYSES AND
CLOUD MIGRATION TECHNICAL AND
DATA MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES.
PLANNING A PLANNING PHASE WILL
PROVIDE THE OVERALL FOUNDATIONAL
STRATEGY AND ROADMAP SUPPORTING
OPERATING MODELS AND DATA AND IT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES. A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
PLANNING PHASE IS WORKING WITH A
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF LOCAL HEALTH DATA
MANAGERS AND ACADEMIA ALLERGISTS
IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED REGIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE. THESE
STAKEHOLDERS WILL PROVIDE THE
INPUT NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH IS INCLUDED
IN CDPH IS UNDERSTANDING OF DATA
AND TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS AT THE STATE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEVELS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF PROCESSES.
ADDITIONALLY IN MY ROLE AS THE
CHIEF DATA OFFICER I KNEW GATES
IN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY DATA
EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK DEVELOPMENT.
ENSURING THAT ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA SCIENCE AND IT
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THIS KEY
INITIATIVE. IMPLEMENTATION IN
THIS PHASE WILL BE SPLIT INTO
TWO KEY PARTS. FIRST THERE ARE
NEAR TERM OFFERS THESE INCLUDE
SHOVEL READY STATE AND LOCAL
PROJECTS ANY ALTERNATIVES AND
LOOK HOW NO CODE PLATFORM
SERVICES. FOLLOWING THE SUBURBS
WILL BE NEEDS A LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS THIS INCLUDES THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ECOSYSTEMS AND BRING
MARKS. APPLICATION SERVICES
CONSOLIDATION AND ENTERPRISE
PORTFOLIO AND DATA GOVERNANCE
AGAIN THE SPACE WILL BE DONE IN
LOCKSTEP AND INPUT WITH. ACTIVE
ENGAGEMENT WITH UCLA JOE SHE ACT
CCL. IT'S DM ME AND THE OUR
FUTURE. THE PLANNING AND AFTER
AND ANY PROPOSED THIS PIECE. OR
ALLOWS. TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
ITS INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SUCCESSES AND OF ALL DATA
SCIENCE INFORMED DECISION
MAKING. LASTLY WE WILL LOOK INTO
A CONTINUOUS MATURITY AND
PROGRAM VALUE DELIVERY IS
ONGOING FEES INCLUDE SYSTEM
STABILIZATION IN TWO YEARS
PLANNING EFFORTS TO ENSURE
FUTURE BUSINESS NEEDS AND
SERVICES ARE BEING MET. AND OF
COURSE MONITORING AND UPDATING
KEY PERFORMANCE INDICATORS AND
METRICS THIS MEANS WILL INFORM
FUTURE NEEDS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT
ALL LEVELS. IS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY THE INVESTMENTS REQUESTED
IN THIS B. C. P. AND THE PATH
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION OF A
MAJOR TRANSFORMATION OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA AND I. T. SYSTEMS.
WILL PROVIDE AN UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE COCA
NINETEEN RESPONSE THIS WILL
TRANSLATE THE BCP FUNDED PLANS
INTO MEANINGFUL ACTIONS WHICH
WILL BENEFIT LOCAL HUNG
JURISDICTIONS. PUBLIC HEALTH
STAKEHOLDERS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND ULTIMATELY. ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR SOME
PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. THANK
YOU- DOCTOR AND BILL- AND
AFTERWARD- SEND YOU PICK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'M- YOU MAY RECALL THAT WHEN WE
ASSESS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
JANUARY FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSAL WE NOTED THAT IT LACKED
AN OVER ARCHING A KEY STRATEGY.
AND THIS PROPOSAL DOES- FILL
THAT GAP- WE ALSO KNOW THE
PROPOSAL DOES LOOK PROMISING IT
FOCUSES ON CREATING SORT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA AND
INFORMATICS ECOSYSTEM FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH COMPLETE WITH LEADERSHIP
TO STRIP TO THINK STRATEGICALLY
ABOUT DATA AND I. T. NEEDS AND
USES- WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A
FEW SUGGESTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION- I HAVE A FEW THAT
ARE. SORT OF HIGH LEVEL AND THEN
WE HAVE A FEW THAT ARE- SORT OF
SPECIFIC TO THE COMPONENTS OF
THE OF THE B. C. P. THE HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS PRIMARILY
CONCERNED LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
TO HELP ENSURE THAT THIS
MODERNIZATION OF DATA AND I. T.
SYSTEMS IS SUCCESSFUL. SO FIRST
I WOULD SUGGEST REPORTING- IN
OUR SYSTEM AND OF THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC PUBLIC HEALTH PROPOSAL WE
HAD SEVERAL- SUGGESTED LAYERS OF
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE
FROM. SORT OF IMPLEMENTATION
UPDATES TO MORE- FORMAL ANNUAL
REPORTS- AS WELL AS A MULTI YEAR
REVIEWS. AND WOULD SUGGEST THAT-
ANY. IT UPDATES ON IT SYSTEMS
BEFORE THAT INTO THAT REPORTING
. I'M NEXT- WE'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
FUTURE PROPOSALS FUTURITY
PROPOSALS IN IN PUBLIC HEALTH SO
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT- MAKES
FUTURE PROPOSALS WE SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE ASK KEY QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THE PROPOSED I. T.
SYSTEMS FITS INTO THIS LARGER-
IT INFRASTRUCTURE AND ABOUT
FUNDING- AS YOU WELL KNOW THE
CDPH PROGRAMS AND I. T. SYSTEMS
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGED BY THE CATEGORICAL
NATURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH GRANT
FUNDING. AND MOST I. T. SYSTEMS
HAVE CONSEQUENTLY BEEN DEVELOPED
SORT OF IN SILOS- LOOKING AHEAD
EVEN WHEN GRANT FUNDING CAN ONLY
BE USED FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT CDPH
CAN'T CONSIDER THE PROJECT WITH
IN THIS OVERALL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND DEVELOP IT TO MAINTAIN
CONSISTENCY SO FOR EXAMPLE MAKE
SURE THAT DATA IS COLLECTED IN A
WAY THAT CAN BE USED ACROSS
SYSTEMS- AND ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY NEW SYSTEMS ARE
INTEROPERABLE WITH OTHER- PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS. SO WE SUGGEST
THAT THOUGH THE LEGISLATURE WILL
WANT TO ASK ABOUT THESE TYPES OF
ISSUES EACH TIME A NEW PROPOSALS
PUT FORWARD. I'M A THIRD POINT-
CONCERNS LOCAL INVOLVEMENT- THE
B. C. P. NOTES THAT PLANNING AND
DESIGN INCLUDES CONSIDERATION OF
HOW THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WILL USE DATA AND
I. T. SYSTEMS. AND IN ADDITION-
MS MOORE NOTED THAT- THAT CITY
PH WILL BE WORKING WITH LOCAL-
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS IN THE
PLANNING. PROCESS THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY VERY KEY AS THE STATE
SYSTEMS DEPEND ON. THE LOCAL
SYSTEMS AND TE LOCAL INPUTS-
WORKING IN TANDEM- WHAT ONE
THING THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER IS WHETHER CDPH
SHOULD REQUIRE THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO INCLUDE. SORT
OF AN IT COMPONENT IN THE PLANS
THAT SO THE LOCL PUBLIC CULTURE
SECTIONS HAVE TO SUBMIT A PLAN-
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
FUNDING AS PART OF THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL- SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER-
REQUIRING CDPH TO. REQUIRE THAT
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- MAYBE ADDRESS THE
STATUS OR WEAKNESSES OF THEIR
OWN A. T. SYSTEMS AND HOW THOSE
MIGHT BE ADDRESSED- AND THEN.
FINALLY ON THESE HIGHER LEVEL
COMMENTS WE ADDRESS RECOMMENDED-
WITH THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSAL THAT THAT PROPOSAL B.
CODIFIED INTO STATUTE VIA
TRAILER BILL AND WE RECOMMEND
THAT THIS PROPOSAL BE INCLUDED
WITH THAT. CURRENTLY
EVERYTHING'S IN PROVISIONAL
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE- SO A FEW A
FEW COMMENTS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF WHICH REALLY STARTS THE
PROCESS OF MODERNIZING THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M FIRST OUR
FIRST COMIC CONCERNS PLANNING SO
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
AUGMENT- IT'S ONE TIME RESOURCES
ONCE. ENTERPRISE PLANNING AND
STRATEGY DOCUMENTS ARE SUBMITTED
TO AND APPROVED BY CAL HHS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY-
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
WHETHER THE PROPOSED- A BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE MIGHT BE AMENDED
SO THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL- A REVIEW OF THESE
DOCUMENTS WILL BE CRITICAL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE FREE MARKET VISION IN
THE PROPOSAL. WILL ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND PART OF THAT
REVIEW SHOULD FOCUS ON WHICH I.
T. PROJECTS AND EFFORTS ARE MOST
CRITICAL TO MODERNIZING THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH IT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO FOR EXAMPLE
SOME OF THE STATE'S- PUBLIC
HEALTH IT SYSTEMS LIKE THE VITAL
RECORD SYSTEMS- MUST REMAIN
FUNCTIONAL. EVEN WHILE THEY'RE
BEING MODERNIZED- OTHER SYSTEMS
HAVE A NUMBER OF INTERFACES WITH
EXTERNAL ENTITIES AND INTERNAL
SMALLER SYSTEMS SUCH AS THE ONES
AT THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTION
LEVEL OR- WITH OTHER HEALTH
SYSTEM. CARE SYSTEMS- AND THESE
THAT NEED YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO MAINTAIN INTER
OPERABILITY- THE ENTERPRISE
PLANNING AND STRATEGY DOCUMENT
SHOULD PROVIDE NOT ONLY THE
LEVEL OF EFFORT REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE- THE IT PROJECTS BUT
ALSO CLEARLY IDENTIFY WHICH
EFFORTS AND PROJECTS ARE MOST
CRITICAL. AND FOR WHICH ANY
POTENTIAL RISKS NEED TO BE
MITIGATED. I'M OUR SECOND N. AND
LAST COMMENT IS THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PROPOSES
IN THE PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO CONSIDER. A VERIFIED
IT SATISFACTORY PROGRESS TOWARD
COMPLETION OF PLANNING IN THE
PROPOSAL- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ASK HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL MEASURE THIS
PROGRESS- AND WHETHER MORE
OBJECTIVE MEASURES OF PROGRESS
SUCH AS THE COMPLETION OF
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS. MEETING
CERTAIN MILESTONES- SHOULD BE
INCLUDED- AND THIS OBVIOUSLY
COULD INVOLVE NOTIFICATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE- WE JUST CLOSE
BY NOTING THAT THE FREE MARKET
GOALS AND VISION OF THIS
PROPOSAL HAVE MERIT. BUT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND EVALUATE
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMPONENTS OF
THE FREE MARKET GOALS AND
VISION. ARE MET INCLUDING ANY
ADDITIONAL- ITEMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO ADD TO
THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DIESS I WILL BEGIN-
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT RESPOND IF WE CAN ON
HOW WE ARE GOING TO BOTH
MEASURE. PROGRESS AS WELL AS HOW
MANY OF THESE WILL FIT INTO THE
LARGER IT SYSTEMS HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON. THOSE CONCERNS REYES
FROM THE L. L. YES THEY CAN'T SO
. REALLY THIS- TIES INTO ALL THE
BCPS EVERYBODY PUTTING IN AND
THE METRICS WILL BE FORMULATED
AROUND AS WE GET THE STRATEGIES
OF THE SPENDING PLAN FOR THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
FOCUSES ON STAFF AND CAPACITY
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMUNICATIONS COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND LOCAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING IT'S NOT
THAT THE SPENDING PLAN
ALLOCATED. LIMITED FUNDING UP
FIFTY K. FOR THREE POSITIONS THE
BAND CALIFORNIA BIRTH AND
DEFECTS MODERATE PROGRAM.
RESOURCES WERE ALSO INCLUDED FOR
THE MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
ESTABLISHED DURING THE CURRENT
FUNDING PANDEMIC. THIS FUNDING
SUPPORTS THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PROGRAM
SUPPORT FOR DISEASE SURVEILLANCE
READINESS RESPONSIVENESS
RECOVERY AND COMMUNITY OF
OPPORTUNITIES CONTINUE ALREADY
OPERATIONS. THE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDING BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATION FOR DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION THAT ENABLES A
MODERNIZATION OF CDPH
INFRASTRUCTURE INFORMATICS
CAPABILITIES THE COR UP AND IN
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH BCPS TO
SHIFT FROM SILENT PROGRAMMATIC
SOLUTIONS. LIKE MENTIONED ON TO
PROGRAMMATIC SYSTEMS THAT LEAD
THAT LEADS THAT COMMUNICATION
DECISIONS TO EXPAND DATA ACCESS
ENABLING ADVANCED PUBLIC HEALTH
ANALYTICS FOR CDPH PARTNERS. I'M
GOING OUT ON IF I CAN EARLIER
YOU INDICATED THAT WE- HAVE AN
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY BEFORE
US AND I'M ALWAYS IN THOSE
MOMENTS TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THERE WERE MAXIMIZING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND. BAND WITH AND
RESOURCES AS WELL- EARLIER WE
HAD- IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
TEN BUDGET HE PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO GO TO LOCAL HEALTH
AND HUNDRED FIRST THE STATE- IS
THERE OPPORTUNITY WITHIN THAT
SOURCE OF FUNDING TO COMBINE AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAXIMIZING
THOSE UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU PRODUCT.
YOUR MANY ANSWER FOR SURE YOU
CAN START LOS UP SURE SO THE
FUNDING ON THE BC IS THAT WERE
UP FOR THE MAINTENANCE
OPERATION. CLICK OR- TO KEEP
THEM. IN CONTINUATION. BERKOWITZ
WE ESTABLISHED THIS NEW FUNDING
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THE
STRATEGY AND PLANNING CORRECTLY
TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE ON THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH ITSELF.
YEAH I'M FROM A PROGRAM
PERSPECTIVE. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT FUNDS THAT WILL GO TO THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. UNLIKE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING WHERE WERE
FOCUSING ON ONE CONDITION AT A
TIME. THIS FUNDING ALLOWS MORE
OF AN UMBRELLA APPROACH WHERE WE
CAN REALLY. COME AT IT FROM THE
BEGINNING EVEN THOUGH OUR
SYSTEMS ARE ALREADY IN PLACE AND
ARE SOME SYSTEMS THAT MAY HAVE
TO OPERATE OUTSIDE OF THE
ECOSYSTEM. AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
BRING THE RIGHTS. STAKEHOLDERS
TO THE TABLE AND TAKE THE TIME
TO DO IT. AND GET THE INPUT WE
NEED IN A MORE COORDINATED
FASHION. SO EVEN THOUGH THERE'S
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO THE
LOCALS AS WELL AS TO THE STATE.
IT'S NOT CATEGORICAL IT'S BROAD
INTENTION WILL PROVIDE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO NOT
ONLY OPTIMIZE BUT MAXIMIZE. OUR
OUR RESOURCES TO THE I. T. AND
THE INFORMATICS AND DATA SCIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I WILL ASK TO
FOLLOW UP WITH MY OFFICE IF
POSSIBLE I AM QUITE INTERESTED
IN INFO MATIX AND BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US. TO
TRANSFORM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND BELIEVE THAT
POPULATION HEALTH IN THE
INFORMATION AND DATA AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISIONS ARE REALLY PREDICATED
ON THE SYSTEMS THAT WE CREATE
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO-
COMMUNICATING AND WORKING WITH
YOUR DEPARTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR
CALIFORNIA. WITH ABSOLUTELY IT.
WITH THAT I WILL THANKS VERY
MUCH- THIS PANEL AND WE WILL AND
WILL THANK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
HERE TODAY IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS COMMENTS WE
WILL NOW BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT WE
DO HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. BLIK COMMENT
IS WELCOME ON ANY ISSUE WHICH IS
ON THE AGENDA. INCLUDING ON THE
NON PRESENTATION ISSUES. WE WILL
START WITH ANY IN PERSON PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THE HEARING ROOM IF
YOU CAN PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE TO MAKE YOUR COME
. TRIMMERS ARE AFRAID NUMBER
REPRESENTING FORMAT AND
REGARDING THE OUTCOME OF YOUR
OFFICES HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY. WE PROVIDED
SUGGESTED LANGUAGE TO THE
MYSTERIES OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA TO BE
COLLECTED WILL REFLECT THE NET
COST TO THE PAYER FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AND IN
ADDITION WE WANT TO BE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT POLICY MAKERS
GOING FORWARD WILL HAVE CORRECT
INFORMATION ON CAR SHARING OUT
OF POCKET EXPENSES IMPOSED ON
PATIENTS. BY THIRD PARTY PAYERS
WE APPRECIATE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN PARTICULAR DR
WOODS OFFICE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I FEEL LIKE SUIT WITH
MANIFEST MEDICS ARE PROUD TO BE
ONE OF CALIFORNIA IS. A
NONPROFIT HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES OR H. ID FOR SHORT. SO
I'M SPEAKING AS A MEMBER OF THE
CYCLICAL MISSION THAT DOCTOR
WOULD GRACIOUSLY AND MENTIONED
IN HIS REMARKS THE MEDIC HOW-DATA SHARING EQUITY CO A
COALITION. OF MY COMMENTS ON
BOTH THE ISSUE SEVEN ON MEDICAID
ENTERPRISE SYSTEMS ON WHICH
THERE WAS A ROBUST DISCUSSION.
AS WELL AS- SSUES EIGHTEEN
WHICH WASN'T PRESENTED BUT IS NO
LESS IMPORTANT ON INTER
OPERABILITY. NOT WHILE THESE TWO
BCPS ARE ARE NECESSARY RESOURCES
FOR DH CS TO ENACT A CENTRAL.
DATA SHARING FOR CALLIN THE
AREN'T SUFFICIENT- THE NEEDS TO
BE FUNDING FOR BOTH DIRECT
INCENTIVES FOR PROVIDERS TO
SHARE GOOD QUALITY CLINICAL DATA
NOT JUST CLAIMS DATA FROM HEALTH
PLANS. AND INVESTMENT H. I. EASE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRACTION BURKE
THIS DATA INTO INSIGHTS AND INTO
ACTION. AND FOR A SECOND PIECE
AS WE DISCUSSED THERE IS AS HIGH
AS A NINETY ONE FEDERAL MATCH
FOR- THOSE RESOURCES. SO PLEASE
WE ASK. THAT YOU JOIN OUR
pELOQUENT CASE FOR BEING MUCH
BOLDER AND FORWARD LOOKING AND
LONG TERM- AND WE ASK THE
ASSEMBLY AND ENTIRE LEGISLATURE
TO ADOPT ARE NINETY FIVE
MILLION. ADDITIONAL EQUITY
PACKAGE INVESTORS STATE BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
MORE PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM
I WILL ASK FOR THE OPERATOR IF
WE CAN GO. TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINE AS A REMINDER FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING
THE PHONE NUMBER AND PASSCODE.
IS ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER AGAIN IS TOLL FREE.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU FOR
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THE- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE WILL GO TO LINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE POLITICAL OR NON GAP OF
ALIGNMENT HEALTH PLAN WHICH
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY NINETY
THOUSAND SENIOR CITIZENS IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M COMMENTING TODAY
ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND WHILE WE
DO SUPPORT THE BRIDE CARE
COORDINATION INTEGRATION CALLED
THE COW IN WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROPOSED INTENDING TO
DO WELL DOUBLE FACIAL NEEDS
PLANNED- EQUIPMENT IT LINED
ENROLLMENT TRANSITION HAPPENING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THIS HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO CAUSE.
MEDICALLY THREE FRAGILE ADD TO
ELIGIBLE SENIORS- WHAT'S OF
THEIR HEALTH PLAN AND BENEFIT-
AND LOTS OF THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER ABOUT PROVIDERS NOT
CURRENTLY IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. AND SO WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO EITHER THE LATEST
TRANSITION- ARCTIC ANOTHER
MODIFICATION THAT WILL ALLOW
THESE BENEFICIARIES TO RETAIN
THEIR HEALTH PLAN. AND THAT
THEY'VE CHOSEN AND. RETAIN THEIR
EXISTING HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
THANK YOU. Q. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WELCOME LINE
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE OF OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANA DOUGLAS
OF HEALTH ACTIVE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION CALLING
INCREASE YOU NUMBER THREE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND SUPPORTING THE
BCP REQUESTS FOR RESEARCH AND
COURSE NOW INVESTMENT. TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE STAFFING TO SUPPORT
TARGET SETTING AND ENFORCEMENT
OF THE OVERALL PROGRAM EVERY
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE IS BEING HIT BY
RISING HEALTH CARE COSTS IN
FEELING THE IMPACT OF STAGNATING
WAGES AND YOU MANY ARE ACTUALLY
FOR GOING CARE. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD AT THE OFFICE WILL
SET EVEN PORTABLE TARGET
ENFORCEABLE TARGETS FOR THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY BY FACTOR IN
ACCOUNTING FOR REGIONAL
VARIATION AND HAVE THE ABILITY
TO LEVEL FINANCIAL PENALTIES OR
OTHER ACTION FOR ONE ENTITIES
EXCEED THE TARGET. AGAIN AND
AGAIN WE SEE IT THAT THE MAIN
COST DRIVER ISN'T. HIGH
UTILIZATION BUT HIGHER PRICE
THAN. EVEN PLEASES OF THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE. INCLUDING PCP
DISCUSSED TODAY THANK YOU FOR
HEARING ARE COMMON. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND THAT'LL COME FROM MINUS
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALKERMES- SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY THAT EVENING TO
ISSUE NUMBER TEN OPIOID
SETTLEMENT OVERSIGHT AND STATE
PROGRAMS. WE GENERALLY FIND A
LOT OF MERIT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WE
APPLAUD THE INVESTMENT AND
EMPLOYMENT IN RECOVERY
PROGRAMMING PUBLIC EDUCATION
YOUTH PREVENTION AND HOW PLEASED
THAT YOU TEACH SERVICES. WELL
THE PROPOSAL WOULD INVEST IN
MANY LAUDABLE EFFORTS IT ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY CONTAINS UP TO LAW
THAT WOULD MOVE CALIFORNIA
BACKWARDS IN ITS. TREATMENT AS
REFLECTED ON PAGE ELEVEN OF THE
BTP FUNDING WOULD PRIORITIZE
WAVERED PRESCRIBERS MEETING
DEEPER DARKER AND TOP
PRESCRIBERS AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHER FDA APPROVED MA T. IT IS
NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CALIFORNIANS TO ELEVATE CERTAIN
O. U. D. TREATMENT OVER OTHERS.
THIS IS A DECISION APPROPRIATELY
LAP TO PATIENTS AND THEIR
PROVIDERS PUT SIMPLY WE BELIEVE
IN THE RIGHT TREATMENT FOR THE
RIGHT PATIENT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
WE HAVE A PENDING MEETING
REQUEST WOULD BE H. THE ASSAM
ACCORD OUTLINING OUR CONCERNS IN
MORE DETAIL AS THE PROPOSAL
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU HAVE A COME FROM NINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY HILLARY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. INTO RESPECT THE
LIMITED TIME FRAME HERE TODAY
YOUR MIND LIMIT OUR COMMENTS.
THE ISSUE SIX REGARDING CALLUM
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE SAM IS
ALREADY PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE
WITH WRITTEN COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS REGARDING VARIOUS
COMPONENTS CAL IMPLEMENTATION
TODAY I WILL HIGHLIGHT ONLY ONE
COMPONENT. OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
MENTIONED IN THE SPRING FINANCED
BUT OUR- CMA CONTINUES TO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
EXTENDING IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COMPONENT OF CALAMP RESTRICTING
A BENEFICIARY'S RIGHT. TO CHOOSE
A MEDICARE DUAL ELIGIBLE SPECIAL
NEEDS PLAN A DECENT BEGINNING IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
UNTIL NECESSARY BENCHMARKS HAVE
BEEN ACHIEVED IN ORDER TO ENSURE
A CAREFUL AND JUDICIOUS
TRANSITION OF THE HONORABLE
POPULATION. AS WE HAVE SEEN IN
PREVIOUS TRANSITIONS INVOLVING
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. THE PATIENT PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIP IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
AND SOMETIMES THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH FOR A
PATIENT. ALLEN IS AN AMBITIOUS
AND FAR REACHING INITIATIVE THAT
WAS SUPPORTED IN LARGE PART BY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION LAST YEAR WHEN IT
WAS HURT BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES OF TALENT.
HOWEVER DH CS IS ALREADY
JUGGLING MANY COMPETING
INITIATIVES AND PRIORITIES THAT
MAY POSE A THREAT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PROGRAMMATIC
DETAILS OF A TRANSITION OF THIS
SIZE AND SCOPE. AT A MINIMUM
THERE WILL BE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF THE MOST FRAIL ELDERLY
SENIORS FORCE CHANGE THEIR
HEALTH PLAN AND LIKELY THEIR
PROVIDER IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AS WE SAW DURING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COORDINATED CARE NASH THAT THE
CCI IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
THE LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT AND
INVOLVEMENT OF PHYSICIANS WITH
MINIMAL. AS A RESULT THE RETURNS
OF THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS THAT
DESCEND ROLLED FROM TCI BECAUSE
THEIR PROVIDER WAS NOT ENROLLED. WITH THE MEDIC HOW MANAGED
CARE PLANS. BETTER THAN. DOCTORS
THE IMPORT OF COORDINATING CARE
FOR OUR POPULATIONS. RECOGNIZE
THAT THE TRANSITION SUCH AS BY
ENVISIONED IN CALLING NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH DUE CONSIDERATION
TO THE NATURE OF THE AFFECTED
POPULATION. IS CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING ACCESS TO CARE
ADHERENCE TO TREATMENT REGIMENS
AND THE OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THE FINGERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU THAT'S COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU HAVE A COME
FROM LINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY
MONSTER GOT BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLAN TO CALIFORNIA PART
OF THE MEDICAL DATA SHARING
EQUITY COALITION SPEAKING ON
BOTH ISSUES AND OTHER ISSUES
SEVEN EIGHTEEN WE ARE HAPPY TO
DEPARTMENTS REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL RULES AND
EXCHANGING IN ADDRESSING. HEALTH
INFORMATION NEEDS BUT I THINK
THE STATE NEEDS A BROADER VISION
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DATA. SHARING TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL
KELLY. SEE IF THE COURT OF THE
COLD SIGN FIVE NO DOLLAR BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND ASK AND THEN IN
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE MONEY TO
INVEST. IN THE ABOUT THE PORT OF
THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS ENSURING
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE DATA AND
FUNDING THE SYSTEM. STATE SYSTEM
NEEDED TO MOVE THE DATA IN A
TIMELY MANNER ADDITIONALLY THIS
REQUEST WIL LEVERAGE ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
AND I HOPE THAT IT WILL BE IN
THE FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU'RE
A COME FROM NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS KIT
MARTINEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE AND BEYOND AND POWER HEALTH
PLAN AND I AM ALSO SPEAKING AT
THE STATE CALL THEIR OF THE
MEDICAL DATA SHARING EQUITY
COALITION. ANACONDA DAY TO
REFERENCE TO ISSUES ON THE
AGENDA SHE SEVEN ISSUE EIGHTEEN
WE ARE GLAD THE DEPARTMENT OF
YOUR QUESTION RESOURCES TO
COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL GOAL ON
EXCHANGING AND PROVIDING ACCESS
TO HEALTH INFORMATION. HOWEVER
THEY NEED TO BE A MRE BROADER
STATE VISION AND FUNDING PATH
FOR DATA SHARING TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF CALLING. THIS IS OUR
COALITION THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET YOU GOT. TO STOP THIS
INCENTIVE FOR MEDICAL PROVIDERS
TO SHARE COMPLETE ACCURATE AND
TIMELY HEALTH RECORDS AND FOUND
A ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE TO MOVE
AND USE THAT DATA TO
CALIFORNIA'S. EXISTING H. I EAT
. THAT'S LOSS OF BRIDGE-
GENEROUS WELL. WE HAVE GREAT TO
MEMBER WOULD FIRST. THE REQUEST
ON OUR BEHALF WE URGE YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US. IN
CALLING FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO A GREATER DATA SHARING EQUITY
PACKAGE IN THE FIGHT IN THE
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU IT'LL
COME FROM MINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF A COUPLE ISSUES FIRST
ON ISSUE THREE THAT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY- I'M
WITH THE COURT FIFTY CTS IT'LL
PUT THE STATE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF TACKLING THE HIGH COST OF
HEALTH CARE AT ITS ROOT. THE
PROPOSAL PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY
HOLDS THE ENTIRE DELIVERY SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR COST GROWTH AND
MOVES US TOWARD YOUR WORDING
QUALITY OF CARE AND PATIENT
OUTCOMES- ON THE SECOND ISSUE
THAT I'D LIKE CON PART OF IT IF
YOU FOR THE B. C. P. FOR. POWER
ACT- DID. HIS PROPOSAL HELP.
LOWER THE HIGH COST OF INSULIN I
JUST BECAUSE OF THE GENUINE
HARDSHIP FOR THOSE WITH DIABETES
AND THE COST FOR MANUFACTURERS
CONTINUE TO WRITE. THE PROPOSAL
WILL PUT AFFORDABLE AND GOING
WITHIN THE REACH OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA THAT IS NEAT. AND
WILL HELP REDUCE HEALTHCARE
SPENDING DRIVEN BY RUN AWAY
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES. AND
LASTLY CALLING IN AS PART OF THE
OF THE STAKEHOLDER OF THE
MEDICAL DATA SHARING EQUITY
COALITION ON ISSUE. SEVEN AND
EIGHTEEN I'M ALSO CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT AS SEVERAL OTHER FOLKS
HAVE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE. TO
SUPPORT THE BASIC PIECE TO BUILD
TOWARDS THEIR ABOUT DATA SHARING
CALLIE NEED. ABOUT IT
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
AND ARE ELIGIBLE FOR. A CRIED
THE NINE TO ONE FEDERAL- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND I'M HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON ANY OF THESE ISSUES. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. GIVE IT
A COME FROM NINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LAN OF THE- GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JACKIE
ANDERSON WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE THE PETITION OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING COMMENTS ON
ISSUES NUMBER TEN AND ELEVEN. I
ON ISSUE TEN WE APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION ON THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUND TRANSFERS
PROVIDED BY MISS COOPER THIS
AFTERNOON. AND WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR OUTREACH
AROUND TREATMENT SERVICES
DISCUSSED BY MISS COOPER WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS AROUND
THE SHIP FROM CDPH WHERE FUNDS
WERE INTENDED TO SUPPORT BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION
MESSAGING. LOCAL DEPARTMENTS
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE AND
VALUE OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
PREVENTION STRATEGIES AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE FUNDS
ARE MAXIMIZED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
ON ISSUE ELEVEN ABOUT CHECK IN
SUPPORT OF A MODERNIZING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IT INFRASTRUCTURE
WE WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION P. THREE P.
AS IT ONLY POINTS THE STATE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DOES NOT
CONSIDER THE LOCAL NEEDS.
CHANGES TO REPORTING SYSTEM THAT
THE STATE LEVEL WILL DIRECTLY
IMPACT THOSE USED BY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN THE
ASSESSMENT AND PRIORITIZATION OF
I. T. NEEDS MUST INCLUDE AND
THAT ENGAGEMENT WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IT
MODERNIZATION SHOULD ALSO BE
INCLUDED IN THE FUNDING OF SUCH
A PROPOSAL GIVEN THE
INTERDEPENDENCE ON STATE AND
LOCAL SYSTEMS. LASTLY WE WOULD
ASK HOW THIS MODERNIZATION TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT OTHER DATA AND IT
INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE CAL HHS
DOT EXTREME EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK.
AND THE CAL IN POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT COMPONENT. WE LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS ARE WELL POSITIONED TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE FRAMEWORK
AND SYSTEM RESULTING FROM OTHER
ONGOING. AND PLANNED
INITIATIVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OPERATOR AN. EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
EVENING CHEN ARAMBULA NUMBERS
EVERYBODY BUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVE ON ISSUE CAN
WE ARE ENCOURAGED WITH THE FIND
COMING FROM THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT WE'RE STILL REVIEWING
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL ON
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
PERHAPS IN THE NATIONAL COMMENT
. SPECIFICALLY ACCORDING TO
PROVIDE BROAD NEWS HAS BEEN
FUNDING FOR OPIOID TREATMENT AND
ABOUT PROPOSAL- HAVE BEEN
LEGISLATURE WHILE KNOWS OVERDOSE
THAT I ROCKETED ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC- IT
CRITICALLY ON THE FUNDING OF THE
NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION PROJECT WE
WOULD LIKE THAT THE FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO BE YOUR **** BOTTLE I
DOUBLE STRENGTH COULD NOT WALK
AROUND OUR MEMBERS CONTINUATION
ON THE GROUNDS WHERE BUT THE
WIDESPREAD AMOUNT- I'M SENTINEL
THAT INDIVIDUAL- WHERE OUR
MEMBERS HAVE TO QUEUE MULTIPLE
DOSES OF NALOXONE IN ORDER
CORRECT THEIR RECORDS OVER DOES
IT THEY WOULD ACCURATE THEY HAD
**** AUTO. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO LOOK AT NEW
AND INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
INCLUDING OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS GET. THE MANAGEMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YOU'RE WELCOME FOR NINE
SIX SIX FELINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS BERNADETTE
ALL OF THEM BUT THE WHITE AND
GRAY I'M- OF MANIFEST MADDOX A
MEMBER AND THE MATTER HOW DATA
SHARING EQUITY COALITION. ALSO
CALLING INTO REFERENCE ISSUE.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN EQUITY COALITION
IS GLAD THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING RESOURCES TO COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL RULES. ON
EXCHANGING PROVIDING ACCESS TO
HEALTH INFORMATION BUT ARE THERE
NEEDS TO BE A MUCH BROADER STATE
NATION AND FUNDING PASSED FOR
DATA SHARING TO ACHIEVE CALLING
ALL OF THEM PROGRAM QUALITY AND
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
YOUR WHOLE PERSON CARE AND A KEY
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
BUILD TOWARD THE ROBUST DATA.
SHARING CAL AND HE IS THE AND
THE OUTSTANDING HIGHLIGHTED AN
ISSUE SEVEN WHAT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR AT HIGHS AND NINE TO ONE
FEDERAL MATCH THIS IS WHY THE
COALITION HAS PROPOSED A NINETY
FIVE MILLION BUDGET INVESTMENT
ESTABLISHING FACTS AS A MEDICAL
PROVIDER STATE SHARE COMPLETE
ACCURATE AND TIMELY HEALTH
RECORDS. AND FIND A ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN MOVES AND YOU
SAT AT YOUR CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES R. COSTA LEVERAGE
GENEROUSLY ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDS WE ARE GRATEFUL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENT FOR SPONSORING THIS
CRITICAL REQUEST ON OUR BEHALF-
JUNIOR COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US AND
CALLING FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO INCLUDE OUR DATA SHARING
EQUITY PACKAGE IN THE FINAL.
BUDGET. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU DON'T COME
NINE FORTY FOUR YEAR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS BILL BARCELONA FROM AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS. ATG IS ALSO
STAKEHOLDER IN THE MEDIC CAL
DATA SHARING EQUITY COALITION
THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDERS ALREADY TODAY.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE SEVEN
IN ISSUE EIGHTEEN. AND WE URGE
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES TO JOIN
US IN CALLING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCLUDE OUR
DATA SHARING EQUITY PACKAGE IN
THE FINAL BUDGET ACT. AND THANK
YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
WOOD FOR. BRINGING THIS FORWARD
ON. CALIFORNIA'S BEHALF. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I MEAN I'M SORRY EXCUSE
ME SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF HIS STAFF NON ALKI
WITH SEIU STATE COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF OUR SEVENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ISSUE PARADE OFF THEIR
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY THE
CPA- SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO BRING
DOWN THE COST OF CARE. PREHEAT
THE WORK BY PLAY NUMBER ONE ANY
MINISTRATION THERE COULD INTO
MAKING SURE THAT WE GOT
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
QUALITY IGNORE ROAD IN ORDER
MEET COST TARGETS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU. AND I EIGHTY FOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO IT'S ME YES
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD- I'M CALLING
BECAUSE I WANTED TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- ISSUE EIGHT
THE COVERT NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES- IT MY IN MY
IN REPLACE IT THIS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY- OKAY
ALL RIGHT. WELL IT JUST SO
CURIOUS TO ME THAT OVER TWO
YEARS LATER WHEN I'M LIKE
LOOKING AT THIS DOCUMENT. AND
I'M SEEING THE TERMS UPON TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT- YOU
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR
INSIST UPON CONTINUING TO FAN.
ON THIS- COVERT SITUATION IT'S
JUST SO PERPLEXING TO ME- AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT REALLY MY
WHEEL HOUSE AND IT'S REALLY MORE
OF A LEAD PERSON I HAVE BEEN
OBSERVING- THE INNER WORKINGS
OF- GOVERNMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. AND- JUST AGAINST THE
BATTER BUT A BIGGER BACKDROP OF
YOU KNOW OTHER STATE THAT. BOB
HANDLED THE COVERT SITUATION SO
MUCH DIFFERENTLY THAN CALIFORNIA
HOUSE AND SOMEHOW WE'RE STILL.
YOU KNOW OVER TWO YEARS LATER IN
THE- LOCKDOWN SITUATION- OR
RATHER MORE LIKE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY PER THE GOVERNOR AND
YOU LEGISLATORS DON'T SEEM TO
BE- DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
AND THEN I LOOK AT THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT- YOU KNOW THERE'S
ALL THIS THE MONEY BEING SPENT.
ON THE THINGS THAT- YOU KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF STATES HAVE HANDLED
MUCH DIFFERENTLY WITH FAR BETTER
OUTCOMES. THAT IS LIKE A COLD
FOR CHILDREN AND YET THIS.
FREIGHT TRAIN OF- MANDATE AND-
THE STRONG ARMING OF PEOPLE JUST
CONTINUES TO STAMPEDE AHEAD AT
THE- SO- I DON'T REALLY HAVE
LIKE ANY- I MEAN I COULD GO ON
FOR HOURS RIGHT I MEAN THERE'S A
REASON THAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THEY DON'T WANT THESE COVERT
RELATED MANDATES AND BILLS TO
PASS AND SO IT'S REALLY ALARMING
FOR ME TO SEE IN THE DOCUMENT
THAT WERE PROVIDED FOR THE
HEARING JUST HOW THIS
INSISTENCE. ON THIS. PANDEMIC IN
QUOTE JUST CONTINUES TO BE. THE-
ANIMATING- PRINCIPAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE AND
- I'M I'M TRYING TO USE MY WORDS
CAREFULLY BECAUSE I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AS YOU
KNOW A CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA AND
JUST AS KIND OF A OF THE FIGHT
TO THAT IT IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
WANT MAKERS AREN'T LISTENING TO
THE PEOPLE AT THIS POINT I MEAN
YOU'RE YOU'RE CUTTING COMMENT IN
THE VARIOUS HEARINGS YOU'RE
DENYING FONG CON ENTIRELY AND-
OTHER HEARINGS. AND SO TO HAVE A
FEW MOMENTS TO SPEAK WITH
SOMEONE IN THE LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY FEEL- RELEVANCE TO ME
IN SOME WAY BUT THE FLIP SIDE IS
- THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THIS IS
. WELL YOU KNOW AND MAYBE THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A OF A
RABBIT YOU KNOW TRAILS TO GO
DOWN I MEAN THEY'RE CONTINUING
TO PULL THEIR CHILDREN FROM
SCHOOL THEY DON'T WANT THEIR
CHILDREN TESTED THEY DON'T WANT
THEIR CHILDREN. TRACK AND TRACE
THEY DON'T WANT THESE VACCINES
AND THEN I LOOK AT A DOCUMENT
LIKE THIS AND YOU JUST WANT TO
SPEND. ALL OUR MONEY. ON A
SITUATION THAT LIKE ENDED LONG
AGO IN FORTY EIGHT OTHER STATES
AND NOW WE'VE GOT THE- BEATING
SCHOOL VARIANT YOU'VE GOT THE-
MEDIA TRYING TO FEAR MONGER
PEOPLE AGAIN AND GOD KNOWS
WHAT'S GOINGON IN L. A. COUNTY
WITH THOSE PEOPLE DOWN THERE.
TRYING TO STRONG ARM THE
CITIZENS BACK IN THE MATH. AND
YOU'VE GOT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TRYING TO TELL THE
SHERIFF WHAT TO DO. AND I JUST
AM NOT SURE WHAT TO MAKE OF YOU
PEOPLE DOWN THERE IN IN
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE- YOU DON'T
SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
ULTIMATELY YOU DO WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE THE DECISIONS ARE ARE TO
MAKE AND IF YOU'RE PAYING EVEN
THE MOST REMOTE ATTENTION TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING FROM PEOPLE
PULLING THEIR KIDS OUT OF THESE
CRAPPY GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS TO THE
FACT THAT THIS IS AN ELECTION
YEAR. I JUST WANT TO THE ONE
USED IN THE IN THE SORT OF LIKE
SPIRIT OF MY- GRANDMOTHER BLESS
HER HEART. YOU FOLKS WHAT A
START TO PAY A LITTLE CLOSER
ATTENTION BECAUSE- ALL THIS
BUDGET MONEY THAT'S GOING O BE
GOING TO THIS. SUPPOSE ED
PANDEMIC. I JUST HAVE TO SAY I
WOULDN'T RECOMMEND IT IT'S NOT
WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING IT'S
NOT WHAT THE PEOPLE WANT THE
PEOPLE ARE EXPRESSING THEMSELVES
IN VARIOUS WAYS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SILENCE
THE POPULATION. AND THIS JUST
SEEMS LIKE SOME KIND OF A OF A
JOB GRAB OR OR OR YOU KNOW POWER
GRABBER JOB SECURITY FOR YOU
LEGISLATORS SO. THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT ITEM
MADE THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN QUOTES BECAUSE- THE
GAME IS UP WE KNOW IT WE'RE SICK
OF IT AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE KNOW
IT'S ALL THEATER SO PLEASE. TAKE
THAT UNDER ADVISEMENT AND SHAPE
THE BUDGET ACCORDINGLY AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME HAVE A GOOD
EVENING. THANK YOU MR WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN Q. LITTLE-
FRAZIER. FOR YEAH THE- YEAH. OUR. THE LIST WE HAVE A PROBLEM
-
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP. JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM WE ARE
ADJOURNED FOR THE NIGHT.